today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza and you know that
today's episode is brought to you by UK
and clothing for anyone who's ever been
told that they cannot do something this
is the clothing for them this is the
clothing that says hey I defy adversity
think about something you can do can you
do it yes that's what you can clothing
is all about sometimes people say oh you
can't you know you can't jump over that
Love Shack on that motorbike you know
I'm saying you can't ahhh you can't hop
over a set of twin sisters on a unicycle
you know why you got a mouthful of fresh
owl eggs guess what you can that's right
so go to defy adversity dot-com and
you'll get 10% off with the promo code
Vaughn they got training where and
Street where so if you're training or if
you're street then you're covered you
can today's episode is brought to you by
this beautiful hood hat
now everybody sometimes once have a hat
that is very specific to their
neighborhood to their area even to the
stoop outside of their apartment complex
well guess what
now you can this one we have right here
is bed-stuy bed-stuy you know it Rocka
Chris Rock jay-z Lil Kim Tracy Morgan
Jackie Robinson all from bed-stuy and at
hood hats you can get all type of New
York style hats that are specific to
your hood quit running around with a hat
that just says New York on it that's not
enough that might not be part of your
life get specific and you can do that
with hood hats the New York collection
just dropped this hat is made from a
hundred percent merino wool from those
beautiful merino animals out there you
ever seen a merino sheep
damnn a soft dude they're not even
usually awake because they so soft it is
fall asleep even if they try to stand up
it's just like cashmere feels really
soft on your head these are made in the
USA America they have 11 total New York
hats
and they are ready to ship you can go
check these outs
we'll put the link right here below just
go to hood hat
h o ody h 8e dot-com and grab these
beautiful hitters man think about your
head where is it
well it could be inside of a hat and
that's factual right there a hat is
basically like an apartment for your
head so if your head is homeless man
change that up and get that bed-stuy
they got all types hood hat or at HUD
hat USA I'll throw them up on my
Instagram as well these hats so specific
get specific hood hat dot-com today's
guest is a psychology professor at the
University of Toronto
he's a critical thinker he's an order
he's a speaker he's currently on tour
he's also the creator of self authoring
which is a program that can help you
examine your past establish your present
and plan your future there'll be a link
to that program below and he also write
when he got here wanted to offer our
listeners and viewers a discount and
that code is th EO Theo and you can use
that for a discount whenever you
purchase self authoring we're so happy
to have him here today mr. Jordan the
Peterson
[Music]
thanks for coming in Jordan hey my
pleasure really appreciate it and I know
our listeners are excited are you
finding like it seems like you've come
into people's lives like a hurricane
really recently do you feel that yeah
and I feel all this has come into my
life like a hurricane - yeah you know I
mean I spend a lot of time teaching
mm-hmm and so I was used to interactions
with reasonably large groups of people
and I did some media work in Canada
before all of this blew up so it didn't
come as a total surprise and I have my
youtube my videos out on YouTube for
quite a while so there's been you know
what do they say it takes 10 years to
become an overnight success and and so
all of this has been building in
multiple ways but but it took when it
took off it really took off like madly
and yeah that was about a year and eight
months ago something like that and and
it hasn't stopped for a second which is
really I keep thinking well the first
week I thought well that's my 15 minutes
and that's that you know and I had
smaller 15 minutes before that but it's
hard to the fact that it doesn't end is
very hard to understand right so but I'm
coming to terms with it I think part of
it is that you know you don't want to
attribute to yourself what can be
tributed to the situation mm-hmm it's a
it's a protection against eagle egoism
pain that he goes a trap
yes it certainly is and so there's all
these people coming out to listen to my
lectures you know I'm I've done 50
cities now in about five months and most
of the theatres that I've been speaking
out have had 2,500 to 3,000 people so
it's a lot of people thinking what the
hell's going on here it's like and then
I thought oh I see I'd see part of it
anyways and it's part of what's your
what you're involved in - is that well
there's a new technology yeah YouTube
and YouTube isn't a technology online
video on-demand is a technology right
and online video on-demand that has no
barrier of cost to production is a new
technology podcasts are new technology
and they're major technology so wouldn't
see about a year two years ago two years
in a few months I noticed that I had
passed a million views on you
because I started to put my lectures up
just out of curiosity and I thought wow
okay what the hell am I supposed to make
of that a million is a lot if I sold a
million books I'd be I'd be happy it
never happens like it's it's a runaway
bestseller you never get a million
citations for a scientific paper that
never happens never a thousand is a hell
of a collection for citations I thought
well what is this place that was
reserved for cute cat videos and I
thought and all these people they're
watching these university lectures there
they're high level lectures you know and
there's a huge public market for it I
thought well that's really interesting
it's like then I thought oh I see here's
what's going on this is a Gutenberg
Revolution the spoken word is now as
powerful as the written word it's just
as widely distributed well and more
people can access it because they don't
have to read and it it uses found time
and there's no barrier to entry and
people can communicate back because they
can cut the videos it's like oh I see
this is this is a revolution right and
so then I think I see what's happening
is the people who are at the forefront
of this are being cascaded forward like
a surfer on a giant wave on this
technological transformation and so you
know obviously people are responding to
my content but a huge part of it is well
there's a whole new medium and it's a to
two of them YouTube that's a big deal
video on demand like that yes which also
enables long-form discussions is huge
you bet but then podcasts they might
even be a bigger deal yeah because
people use fountain time and so that's
really helped me put it in perspective
I'm actually happier about that because
you know you might think well isn't it
gratifying to know that your message is
reaching well now it's millions of
people and it's like yeah but if there's
danger in that it's like well what the
hell why am i at the center of this or a
center of this like is there something
special about my messages there's
something special about me it's like and
you might think well I hope so it's like
no you don't necessarily hope so yeah
you know it's very dangerous it is very
dangerous online well yeah and it also
puts you in a very peculiar position and
it's like oh no I see what's happening
is I am an early adopter of a
revolutionary technology oh yes that's
good and then fine I'm competent at it
and hopefully what I'm doing is help
but let's not underestimate the
technology right let's not underestimate
I know you mentioned on Rogen on Joe
Rogan's recent episode that how you were
a surfer and not the wave itself exactly
do you find though that is it like do
you find like can you start to see how
dangerous and powerful the ego can be
though a little bit because I even
notice in my own life like starting to
sell out shows and stuff in the past
year and people coming in like people
being excited to spend time with me you
know sometimes it's not even about the
word it's just about maybe who they you
know relate to you as as a person yeah
but I do notice that it can be very
dangerous I see how that can be
extremely dangerous if I don't stay in a
place where it's not about me well I
think I think the best antidote to that
well so yeah that's a mask some of it is
happening well I'm older a and so I
think it's less - all that's less
tempting for me right and I've had a lot
of clinical experience in that sort of
thing and I've I also know why it's
necessary to keep your ego under control
and and that's certainly the case also
if you do psychotherapy because people
well you're in a position of authority
let's say mm-hmm and it's easy for that
to become inflated but it's not good for
you and it's not good for your clients
you have to keep your feet on the ground
and they're not coming to you for sage
advice clients they're actually coming
to you so that you can listen to them
figure out how to sort their own lives
out that's a really important
distinction and then with regards to the
people coming to see me the proper
attitude towards that and I think this
is true for any performer is gratitude
you bloody well be happy those people
are there and so I'm I'm careful like I
am I do meet and greets after the events
and I'm watching myself to make sure
that I'm always happy to meet the next
person you know because I know that if I
start getting tired of it maybe it's
only from exhaustion you know that I
should stop doing it because it is an
absolute privilege to have these people
come and you should never take that for
granted and you should never think
there's something you know spectacularly
special about yourself that's attracting
these people and that somehow you're
above them and and they're your fans or
you know that there's this real power
differential even though that sort of
manifests itself because people are so
happy to see you right but
but that's a dangerous pathway and I
truly am ridiculously overwhelmed and
grateful and happy and pleased did all
these people show up yeah especially
because of what also is happening you
know um what what I'm like it seemed
like it I you know one of the things
that I found most powerful in your
recent episode with with which you're
going to keep citing that but that you
know you talked about how many people
came out and he talked about a like a
Latino boy yeah he actually had a funny
it was funny I thought the joke was
pretty funny how you're like when two
guys run up on you downtown so nice is
it's a little bit alarming usually yeah
but it was uh it was um um it was a
Latino boy and his father and they were
talking about how the relationship had
gotten better since they gotten somehow
gotten you into their life yeah yeah
well they were working hard to the boy
in particular the young guy was working
hard in particular obviously his father
was responding but the the young guy had
made that a priority right sided he was
gonna fix his relationship with his
father and then it was working it's like
yeah well that's just great and I hear
stories like that all all the time just
non-stop and how does it make you feel
that like I noticed that that makes you
and make you what is that feeling though
well I'm thrilled right and and you know
it's funny to use that word because I
often teach people to negotiate for
their salaries it's like okay you're
negotiating for a new job you're
negotiating for a race what should you
ask for that's easy
figure out how much you'd have to be
paid so that you were thrilled to have
the job and then tell the person look
you know you got to be reasonable about
it right you know it's got to be within
the bounds of sensibility you know but
you might think okay well I need to be
able to get up in the morning and thank
God I'm it's so good that I get to go do
this job it's like okay how much do you
have to be paid to do that and you can
ask yourself that about almost anything
that someone asks you to do it's like
okay if I'm gonna do this what are the
preconditions for me so that I would be
thrilled to do it and then well then
then you can tell the person and they
are burdening and you and you get to be
thrilled right and and with this with
what I'm doing right now well I am
thrilled because I do believe I truly
believe that the way out of this idiot
political polarization were and in the
and the danger we're in the existential
danger is for people to get their lives
together individuals one by one and
every time one individual
gets their life together that actually
measurably makes the world a better
place and I truly believe that and so
when it isn't that I believe it is that
I figured out why that's true it's not
the same thing as just believing it
right you seen it no I've seen lots of
times and I also know that like you're
not an isolated dust mote among seven
billion specks it's like you're Network
man yeah like you know well you're
you're a really good example of that you
have a lot of influence it's like it
actually matters whether you have your
life together you're influencing a lot
of people and then they're influencing
other people so it's teamwork I mean I
noticed even just starting this podcast
right which we started around the same
time as yours that I now show up for the
podcast because the listeners show up
for me yeah it's really fascinating you
know it's like I'll come in at extra
hours and do extra things because I want
to us to be a part of each other's along
yeah yeah yeah well and that's a great
that's a great philosophy for making it
work because the other thing you have to
do and I've been trying to do this with
this book and also with the like I
published this book and I told the
publishers look man I'm all in I'm doing
everything I possibly can to make and I
mean everything flat out to make this
book a success because I that's why I
wrote it I'm not half in I'm all in and
if you're all in well first of all that
increases the chance of success it's
actually the only way of testing whether
you have the chance of success you're
gonna be all in you got to be all in and
then this that means for anything that
means a book a job or relationship
anything you got to be all in and it's
even true if it's a you know you might
think well I work in a diner and it's
like should I be all in and out it's
like yeah man you could make that a good
diner yeah and then everybody that comes
in there could have a good 20 minutes
half an hour a decent meal you know a
little break they could have good cup of
coffee they could have some fresh orange
juice yeah to be it could be good part
of their life and then you'll learn how
to make a good diner and and a place
that's hospitable to people you learn
how to treat people properly and you'll
learn how to treat your customers
property and make your business grow and
then even if you stop doing that even if
you're being a waiter or waitress you
know which when I was waiter for four in
many places I've lived in many
restaurants it's like you can learn an
awful lot doing that and then if you
want to go do something that's that's
different then you can bring everything
you learn from that forward and it's not
trivial it's not a trivial thing to be a
good waitress or a good good whole
store a good short-order cook man those
are those are tough jobs and if you do
them well it matters mm-hmm so do you
find I find when I'm in you know when
I'm in your home country when I'm in
Canada people there's a lot there seems
to be there's some infection in America
sometimes I feel that we've lost a sense
of like pride or a sense of self that
there is value in even doing like the
small things and in your cut I mean you
know in Canada I was just performing in
um in Calgary for a couple for a couple
of nights and had a and had a blast
people are so nice I mean like you could
literally have one leg and somebody come
up and give you their other you know
their leg and they'll just stand there
you know like a flamingo and just you
know let you go live your life I mean
people are just so so affable and so
kind but yeah but there seem to be a
little bit more sense of like Canadian
pride there and in America I feel like
we've lost a little bit of that pride
like in our in ourselves but also even
in our country just an overall pride
issue kind of yeah yeah well I think
that's been under assault you know the
idea that you should have pride in your
country you know that that's kind of a
fascist thing or that you should you
should
what would you say have respect for your
founding principles that idea is sort of
under assault the idea that this is a
corrupt patriarchy and that it's an
oppressive state and it's like well it's
corrupt except compared to every other
system that's ever existed right we're
doing a lot better okay so many oh well
yeah and then the degree to which
American ideals but Western ideals more
generally have made their manifestation
throughout the world is producing a
massive increment living quality
everywhere yeah you know there's lots of
look it's it's not like our systems
don't have problems they have problems
like all systems but as far as systems
go man we're we're running on eight
cylinders yeah you're doing all right
and so yes suddenly it's like we're
doing so badly yeah and I love how
suddenly it's happened like all of a
sudden everything is horrible and really
when you get out into the world most
things are fine I'm noticing especially
in America it's a lot of the media is
just saying that things are bad and then
there's a lot of people sitting at home
sharing that information yeah well I
think you go outside it's not that way
that people are generally be
pretty decent to each other I think part
of what's happening is that as the
classic media died under the onslaught
of this technological pressure
especially television yeah television is
habit oh it's so if it's too efficient
it's efficient to the point where it's
not effective I think well and the
bandwidth is so narrow and it's so
heavily advertised and you know you get
turned into a commodity on TV no matter
how good your character is it tends to
turn you into a commodity yes of the
narrow bandwidth and so I think what's
happening as the media and of course the
print media is just facing competition
on every possible front right because so
many people have access to - oh yeah
every writing and sharing well exactly
there's nothing special about being a
journalist anymore
now essentially and it's jump the shark
in the past year like it's fascinating
how quickly all of that just oh yeah hit
almost rock bottom oh yeah man it's
unbelievably fast well that just shows
you how powerful the technologies are
but you know I think as the traditional
media dies they get desperate for
attention they get all clickbait tees
yes they add the the exaggerate the
polarization and the catastrophe the
best example of that is there's way more
coverage of violent crime than there was
25 years ago but there's half as much
violent crime like in the five major
measures of violent crime have fallen by
50 percent in the last 25 years like who
knows that no one oh it's dangerous the
streets are dangerous we're all at each
other's throats it's like no we're not
it's safe for now in the United States
than it's ever been it's safer now than
it was in the early 60s you'd never
guess that well then you know it's funny
I was just back I went back to my
hometown which is a small town in
Louisiana and you said you're from a
similar we just figured out before we
started about 4,000 people
yes eyes town and I was asking some of
the teachers at my junior high school I
said well what is racism like here now
because you know my town was just poor
black and poor white mostly and she goes
you know what and this is a girl who'd
went to school with me and who's now the
principal there she goes you be you'd be
surprised because it's gotten so much
better he's like we just don't have you
know we definitely have some differences
in class for sure still but we don't
have as much just outright racism
anymore and that was and for that to
happen like am i telling her grew up in
a town there was a lot of rate there
there was a lot of
you know when I was growing up there
weren't there wasn't any black wealth I
mean those like the Dallas Cowboys and I
think like Eddie Murphy were the only
wealthy black people that you even heard
about in the whole universe
and then now you know it's a lot
different in America like you can go to
Atlanta where you get to see like a lot
of black prosperity and some of that's
just taken time yeah but I wondered
sometimes like man will some of these
smaller towns where places where I'm
from will they ever be able to get some
of that you know that that that guttural
like you know vulgarity of old racism
you know of old practices out of out of
our you know a pro system out of our DNA
and to hear that firsthand from people
that I trust you know teachers at this
school that that that's getting better
the kind of like it was like wow cuz
that's crazy because if you click on
anything online everybody's you know
killing each other over racist ideals
yeah so yeah it's just the world that I
live in then I see is a lot much better
than the world that's online and I think
people are starting to realize I think
they are too people are awakening so
fast and and that brings me to a
authenticity like do you feel like for
you because there's a lot of voices out
there you know and you are on a platform
now where it's bigger and people can
talk more and people can you know it's
nobody's clicking on the one sentence
anymore because they know the one
sentence it's part of a huge
conversation they'd only get to know
what it all happened and now they want
the whole conversation they want to know
who that is but do you feel like for you
up that you're coming along at like like
I'm 38 you know I mean I'm kind of a
late bloomer so I'm kind of maybe like
30 to really but I'm also like an old
soul so I guess I'm actually like I'm
back at 38 but it's a quick trip yeah
yeah but you know I grew up in a time
like you know a lot of our fathers and
my friends father's like you know they
got divorces they went for like younger
women or they you know they gave in to
this idea that they could have it all
you know uh you know I I saw my mother
not you know have to work hard and not
get a kiss on her forehead before bed
you know like she always had to be the
one giving out any affection in her
house
some you know I noticed that you know
there's a lot of men my age who it's not
about the fight there's nothing for us
to do you can't reprimand your children
anymore it's an you can't fight anymore
it's more about lawyers it's like I just
feel like there's a lot of men arriving
at a point in their lives with like what
is it is there any value in me even
being a man hmm
and like our fathers were in Wars and
our fathers were in military and there
was some you know there was a I was an
American or but I feel like there's this
aimless kind of there's a lot of men
wandering around aimlessly a lot of
confusion too because what they're
listening to you mm-hmm
yeah well men they're finding you yes
like it's like you're like this cool
step there that showed up that actually
like cares about our mom or something
yeah you know not to put a pressure on
you no no that's a good one but I'm good
one I'm noticing from some of my like
esteemed friends people men that are way
smarter than me and when men that have
bigger hearts than million they're
reaching out to me they're so excited
they're like oh you have Jordan coming
in today you know he touches me like I
they feel connection yeah well I
actually would I'm actually as I said
I'm actually thrilled and when you know
and all sorts of people are coming up to
me after the talks and on the streets
and so forth and saying you know a fair
number of them are our guys often
younger but not always and you know they
want to come up and tell me something
good that they've done and I'm thrilled
about it's like good man get out there
kill it yeah and the idea like because
part of what's happened in the dialogue
in our culture is that masculine
responsibility the the willingness to
shoulder responsibility which is part of
what factors into achievement and the
mission it's really the really the part
of it that's all right positive is being
confused with tyranny and oppression and
so that men are in in large part being
punished further for their best impulses
right you want to get out there and like
do something like while doing things
wrecks the earth right it's like well
the earth is recognized so it's only
just that we you know that we defend
ourselves a little bit and it's also
just wrong is like doubt that
willingness to go out there and contend
with the world to go on your adventure
right and to take the risks and the
entrepreneurial risks and the risks of
discipline and risks of responsibility
and to and to buttress and support the
family system and the community system
that's all incredibly laudable but for
me it's more than that because I think
of it as a bulwark against hell and I
mean I mean that both literally and
metaphorically it's like it's actually
vital that you take your place in the
world and you find a meaningful
responsible path forward because it's in
that pathway that you find the meaning
in your life and that buttresses you
against the catastrophe of life and if
you have if you don't have that you have
the aimlessness
and the suffering and the pointlessness
and your own malevolence and bitterness
it's it's hell yeah and then you make
hell for you and you make hell for your
family and you make hell for the
community it's like none of that's good
and so whenever I see people step away
from that they're moving forward and
they're telling me about it I think and
I really think great that's a miracle
man keep it up like it's really
important and I don't care what you're
doing you know and I have lots of
respect for working-class guys I mean I
came from a little town I've had all
sorts of working-class jobs you know I
worked on a I worked as a short-order
cook and I worked as a bartender in a
rough cowboy bar a couple of them I
worked as a drill bit Reid temper and a
gas jockey Anna and I worked on rail
crew put in Lion foot railway lines
through and worked as a beekeeper and
and then plywood mill lots and lots of
jobs like that yeah you know and I've
renovated houses and and so I've worked
with lots of contractors and so forth
and I like I think working-class guys
the whole bloody world rests on their
shoulders it really matters if they do a
good job and so a lot of working-class
guys come to my shows and they say look
I've been listening to your lectures
well I'm I'm doing long-haul trucking or
while I'm working in my forklift or
whatever I think great man get the hell
out and do your job properly you bet and
do it right support your family man the
hell up live a responsible life and and
what you're doing is valuable I don't
care what anyone else has to say about
it yeah I've heard I'm in a 12-step
program in a a right so I wasn't out you
know I'm in recovery so almost two years
now and that really changed my life
getting in new you know twelve steps and
you know we'll you know and I know
that's your book but I
one of the things that stuck in these
esteem will people do esteem Abul things
and it's like right and it's like when
you have that choice to do something
better than alcohol man yeah yeah the
funny thing is if you're trying to stop
drinking you need something better than
alcohol and alcohol is pretty good yeah
so you better find something a lot
better man yeah and then it is then
estimable people do esteem abaut things
it's like yeah well you want to figure
out you want to figure out something
that you're doing with your life that's
worth not getting drunk and screwing up
yeah right because that's fun you want
to have something on the other side of
that teeter-totter that has some value
you bet you had and so that you can
think no no I'm not gonna get drunk and
screw that up
right cuz you know P you might say well
why do people drink too much it's like
if you like alcohol that's a stupid
question
yeah right what if they drink too much
well because it's great you know it's
like okay so why stop well you do stupid
things when you're drunk you hurt
yourself you compromise your health it's
really hard on the people around you you
tend to turn into a liar and it screws
up your life yeah it's like yeah but
it's pretty fun yeah well it is but you
need something better than that and
what's better isn't being straight and
and and not making mistakes it's like
that's all prohibition in some sense
what's better is no you need an
adventure man you need to get out there
and have something to do yeah and and
something worth waking up for and you
need that's the substitute for the
addiction actually the addiction is the
substitute for that if truth be known
right but eventually you can flip that
around and you can find that you know
the the much girthier and and more
there's a lot of sexy weight and having
self-worth hmm you know and that's what
I've started to slowly find in my life
yeah and you might also like the thing
to is you know I mean there's something
kind of I don't know the the bar scene
that the heavy drinking scene there's
something kind of edgy about it you know
on some kind of adventurous about it and
you know you see that it's kind of
dramatized in people like Tom Waits he's
got that real hard edge or Johnny Cash
or people hard livin guys oh yeah 67
livers in them yeah yeah exactly yeah
well there's some kind of romantic about
that yes and and fair enough you know
but well then what that means is you
have to build something like that into
your own life so maybe you need to go
maybe you need to you know take an
adventurous trip now and then you got to
have something there that that that's
that
ng to replace that and sometimes if
people need a catalyst so there's that
moment right like for me the catalyst
was like you know I needed to probably
have an experiment with cocaine and I
sacrificed like a neat job opportunity
with that I had planned on being there
for the job and next thing you know I'd
spent the night doing cocaine I realized
okay this is not this is a little out of
my control so I have to make this but if
this if you don't have that sort of how
do they create is there a way to create
their own catalysts like you just said
like take a trip well one thing okay so
one of the things we talked about
talking about is I have this program
online called you can find it at self
authoring dot-com or you can find it on
my website yeah both the links right
here okay so one of the program the
program's help you write about your life
and by the way you don't have to be able
to write very well to do this and if you
do it badly that's just fine as long as
you do it because doing it is badly is
way better than not doing it at all
which is kind of like a motif for life
right get the hell out there and do it
you're not gonna do it perfectly but
it's better than not doing it at all you
make your mistakes but you'll learn one
part of the program which is the future
authoring program helps people develop a
plan for their life you actually need a
plan for your life because the thing is
the plan gives you goals they think
staying mad and like imagine you went to
their the shooting range and you didn't
have a target mm-hmm what the hell fun
is that we're gonna do shoot your rifle
into the air there's nothing about that
that's useful your friends you're why
you're still shooting right but it's not
fun right there's no there's no game
that's right then the game is to hit the
damn target okay so first of all there's
no game without a target all right so
fine you need a target and then you
might say well is the game worthwhile
and the answer might be well how how how
challenging is the challenging is the
place that you put the target if it
isn't challenging enough if it's
challenging enough the game will be
worthwhile well there you go that's the
secret to life it's like if what you're
aiming at is challenging enough the game
will be worthwhile well it's not
worthwhile it's like well reconfigure
your aims then you're not aiming high
enough by your own judgement say well
this isn't meaningful it's like hey man
you're not aiming high enough because if
you were it would be meaningful yeah
that's the okay so while the future
authoring program says like look the
first thing you want to do is decide
that you
responsible for taking care of yourself
like you're someone hypothetically
worthwhile okay so that's the first
thing it's like the same Samand you have
a kid and you like the kid and you'd
like things to go well for them so you
got to have that attitude towards
yourself right despite all your flaws
which are manifold and that's hard for a
lot of people to get to oh god yes and
no wonder because you know most of us
are fixer uppers and we need some work
and so it's not so easy to come out with
the whole self-love which is not
something I'm not that comfortable with
anyways but the fact that you're not
perfect doesn't mean that you aren't
worth improving that's that's the thing
I love that so okay so then the next
thing is so get yourself in that state
of mind just assume it maybe there's
something in me worth redeeming all
right next thing assume that if you aim
at it you might at least be able to get
close to it okay right or that you'll
aim at it miss but your aim will get
better across time and you're taking a
shot in the right direction that's
exactly it and you're starting to move
in the right direction and even if you
haven't got your your goals specified
properly as you move towards them you'll
get smarter and you'll be able to make
better gyoon so you're on the right
truck calibrate you're starting to crawl
exactly what you're doing you're
starting to calibrate that's exactly it
and then the next issue is okay now
here's another hypothesis if you aim at
it you might get it hmm but you're not
gonna get it if you don't aim at it
right you might not get it if you aim at
it but you might get it so that's at
least your lit setting up the
preconditions right next step imagine
you live three three to five years down
the road and you get you get to have
what you need and want
assuming you're reasonable okay so these
are things to consider how would you
like your family to be if it could be
the way you wanted it to be what are
gonna do with your relationships with
your siblings and your parents what
about your kids and your wife your
intimate relationship right if you could
have what you wanted what it would look
like your career or your job what's it
gonna be and how are you going to
conduct yourself in it how are you gonna
educate yourself cuz you're not as smart
as you could be you need to know some
more things because unless your life's
perfect you're too ignorant that's
basically the issue how are you gonna
take care of yourself mentally and
physically how are you gonna withstand
the temptations of drugs and alcohol
what are you gonna do outside of your
work that's productive engaging and
meaningful okay so that's seven things
it's just even hypothetically if you
could have what you wanted
what it looked like okay next thing um
right for 15 minutes about what your
life could be like in three to five
years if you had what you want just so
you know if you had what you want if you
had what you wanted what would it be
right I can don't be ridiculous
right about it it has to be it has to be
high castle within your egg in it you
have a castle in the air
well except they won't stay in the air
so like you know let's stay living to be
laws well there it's gonna be long gonna
tax you probably there's gonna be other
people that you have to take into
account so let's assume this is like in
the real world and everything just so
that we can okay yes 100% okay so do
that next thing take stock of your
idiocy z' and weaknesses and assume that
in three to five years they auger you
into the ground and you were in the
worst hell you could design for yourself
that's probable right out that because
that gives you something to avoid
because when you're turned that you're
thinking well i have something difficult
to do why the hell should i bother it's
like oh yeah so I won't end up in that
hell right right because part of it is
well I want to get to where I want to go
that's kind of nice it's hopeful and it
makes you positive but that's not enough
you also need to be terrified out of
your skull yeah and the only way to do
that properly well I'm sure this must
have happened when you just started to
stop drinking you must have thought this
isn't good I'm not gonna be funny
anymore I thought that I like I thought
there was gonna be ramifications yeah
okay and so what were they what what did
you what did you foresee happening I
thought I wouldn't be funny I thought
that people wouldn't like me I thought
that I wouldn't be able to meet girls if
I wasn't drinking or or you know or
having drugs or right so that was what
you were afraid of giving up if you
stopped drinking right what were you
afraid of happening if you kept drinking
um I was afraid of not achieving my
dreams I was right rate of you know
ending up a drug addict yeah it's sort
of dying in my sleep something you know
dying under the inflow that like that
doesn't happen to comedians right ones
the law well exactly well it's not an
occupational hazard because you're up
late at night in your own bars all the
day it is it is because it is because
you're up late at night it Carly right
here right right one it happened to all
sorts of comedians and rock musicians
usually happens at about 27 you know
weirdly enough
so okay so you were afraid you're afraid
you're gonna die are you afraid you're
gonna become addicted so so let's say
what what of life what would have life
like being like you for you if you were
addicted so you don't have a career
anymore no right so you given all that
up and failed so that's fun so that's
gonna drive you even more time towards
drugs yeah it would have been all my
dreams it would have been miserable
right right then hell exactly is that so
why quit drinking so I don't end up in
hell hey there's a reason there's a
reason to stop and then if you make that
hell real it's like here's all the
details of my personal hell yes let's
avoid that right so then you have
something to run the hell away from
right so you have some rewards and
something run away from and I'll say
this too as you for if there's any young
man or women out there we were listening
to Jordan feeling like well I still I
don't know if you know if I start doing
something different like my friends are
gonna act too sir yeah they are they are
yeah you're also you're gonna start
creating conversations you're gonna
become the entry because you're gonna be
bringing something new to the table
you're also gonna find out who your
friends are yeah because if you're
starting to put your life together and
you have friends that object those are
not friends those are just people you
know they're not friends because a
friend is someone this is one of the
hallmarks of a friend here's two
hallmarks mmm-hmm a friend is someone
you can tell bad news to and they won't
tell you why you're an idiot and they
won't interfere with your sulfurous
listened they'll just listen and maybe
they'll suffer along with you okay so
you can tell bad news to them and they
won't tell you some worst thing that
happened to them they'll listen now
suffer along with you but a friend is
also someone you can tell good news to
and the friend will say Wow
in this vale of tears something good
happen to you great man can grab
wonderful it's rare it's unlikely good
for you I hope ten more things like that
happen and they're not envious and
they're not jealous and they're not one
up on you and if you're trying to get
your life together it's actually if
you're trying to get your life together
and your friends get in the way that's
actually real useful for you because
you've now identified who your friends
aren't mm-hmm and you might think well I
can't give them up it's like oh yes you
can and not only can you you should and
it would be better for them because if
they're aiming down and they want you
going down with them there's nothing
good about what's happening to them and
there's certainly nothing good
not for you yet they're not gonna and
then they're gonna learn wow if I I'm
gonna lose friends if I continue in
these directions yeah exactly exactly is
it hard for why is it hard for people to
let go of what so familiar with to them
even if it's bad
well because it's complicated you know
and the thing that's a really good
question you discount the risk of
familiarity that they're familiar with
so like let's say because people are in
relationships people are in
relationships with the drugs and alcohol
people in relationships with humans
people are in relationships with jobs
people in relationships with their own
selves and they deliver they're living a
lie every single day but it's it's
familiarity yeah well you say I have a
job I hate it's like well yeah but I'm
not dying from it it's like not as bad
as it can be so you kind of you kind of
that you've factored in the risks
already they get invisible you think
well I can't jump out of this job
because what about all the risk it's
like yeah no kidding you got to make a
you've got to get your resume in order
you got to send it out you got to send
50 of the damn things out before anybody
will call you back then you have to go
get interviewed and maybe you're not any
good at that you have to come up with a
story while you're a good employee and
maybe and maybe you're not yet so you
have to figure out how to do that it's
like what about all these risks if I go
look for a new job it's like yeah
absolutely man those are risks and
they're harsh and no wonder you're
avoiding them what about the risks for
you to stay with this job you absolutely
hate well let's think that through okay
so I have this dead-end job I hate it
I'm getting better where am I gonna be
in five years I know where because I've
watched this with people you're gonna be
you're gonna be just like you are now
except a lot more of what's good about
you is going to be gone hmm and a lot
more of what's terrible is going to be
amplified and you're gonna be like in
five years you're gonna be ten years
older instead of three years older Yeah
right
and cuz it kills your spirits oh man
yeah so it's like you think oh my god
there's a terrible risk in pursuing this
new job it's like yeah there is a
terrible risk there's a terrible risk
and you stand with your job right now
and so one of the things that's really
really freeing to understand is that
you're screwed no matter what you do ah
there's no secure path forward give it
up it's risk everywhere oh my god that's
terrible it's like yes except for two
things you can pick your risk that's the
first thing so we get to pick your
poison
something and second you're a lot
tougher than you think so even though
there's risk everywhere if you confront
it forthrightly what you'll find is that
you can actually handle the risk and
that's the security that's beautiful and
there's so much growth to be had right
there when you realize how much like
there were times I was like man I could
never be a sober person because I'm
afraid of you know I can't communicate
with women or I'm afraid to you know
stand around in a circle with tough guys
without having like a beer in my hand
you know we're like all these little
crutches you know I can't and then I
remember when I got like 90 days sober I
was just like holy [ __ ] man like it was
like the first time I'd ever done
something like for myself you know yeah
and it just man it felt it felt
unprecedented yeah yeah well it was not
like I'd gone to the moon how old were
you when you started drinking uh I'm
probably like 17 or 16 you know kind of
regular yeah it was pretty basic and I
never did a bunch of it you know but my
biggest thing was just emotional
sobriety like I was so drunk on my own
insecurities and low self well i'll
qahal alcohol really is a good drug for
coping with anxiety that's when people
use it so it does - if you if you really
like alcohol it does it does two things
to you it makes you more extroverted and
enthusiastic well you're on the
ascending limb of the blood-alcohol
curve which is why you have to keep
drinking once you start because if you
plateau that goes away so you got to
keep drinking okay so that's one thing
it makes you more enthusiastic and and
more full of positive emotion and the
second thing it does is reduce anxiety
yeah so if you are a bit more socially
anxious and you also have that positive
response to alcohol which everyone
doesn't have by the way then it's a
great drug but the problem is it's well
it's a great drug for the moment right
right there's there's consequences yeah
then it's not great well I did also the
alcohol is an interesting drug because
it it it actually doesn't make people
stupid this has been tested like alcohol
true people who are drunk will take far
more risk and you might say well that's
because they're too stupid to understand
the risk it's like no they're not if you
ask them about the risk when they're
drunk they can outline it perfectly what
it stops them from doing is caring about
the risk it's actually and that's part
of the anti-anxiety components like yeah
the risk is that's why you
drive around drunk at high speed in a
car which is a really stupid thing to do
yeah we used to do that in the back
roads of northern Alberta it's fun yeah
you know but but people died all the
time doing it especially in the winter
it's like wow this is great it's great
until your head's going through the
windshield you know like so many things
yeah it's like jumping off a cliff it's
I'm flying that's true until the last
1/10 of a second like then you're not
flying man yeah yeah yeah so so alcohol
alcohol has exactly that effect it is a
great and anti-anxiety drug but it does
stop you and he said it stopped you from
learning the skills that you need in a
social circumstance to be able to cope
with that so then it actually stops you
from dealing with the anxiety you don't
have to learn how to overcome it that's
not good yeah so yeah yeah you're not
really learning you're kind of just
staying in the you're just you're
baiting the egg your your kind of
meeting the anxiety with a little bit of
light medication but you're never
getting through whatever the anxiety was
yeah you don't look you don't have to
learn the skills well you said you like
to stand there with a beer in your hand
we'll give you something to do you
didn't know what else to do then you
didn't have to learn I had the same
issue like I started drinking when I was
13 probably yeah and and that's late in
Canada yeah that's right I was way
behind my neighbors they were slogging
it back when they were four oh I've been
in Edmonton and I've seen people I mean
it's just people love to drink up Dave
it's a fun culture right it's a cordial
thing on the farther north you go the
more the drinking becomes necessary in
the winter you know so and there's not
that much to do in those isolated small
town yeah I drink I drink my own blood
probably I when I used to go back to the
little town I was from when I was an
adult even if I had never really had
anything to drink for years it was like
well what are we gonna do well let's go
to the bar why well because there
actually isn't anything else to do so
you know and so you end up there but but
but the alcohol is it's well it's a hell
of a drug do you think watch it do you
think it's going to start get out to get
outdated I start to think that alcohol
is almost a drug of the past slowly like
I could see us like with psychedelics
and stuff like that becoming a little
bit more in like the common sphere of
conversation well be interesting to see
that we just legalized marijuana in
Canada yeah yeah like it's not
not completely legal yet but the bill
was passed so Canada is doing this
countrywide experiment and I know there
is some data showing that in counties in
the US where marijuana has been
legalized the overuse of opiates for
pain has decreased substantially the
crime rates have gone down interesting
laws don't PBS don't pause it's hard to
pick somebody's pocket yeah break it to
a building I don't think so it's not
gonna get it together you might not for
a long time yeah you might knock at the
front door with the other break-in and
you're not gonna make it you might
that's right you're not gonna go what
are you gonna go on the Le and have a
fight no you know what real slow fight
while you're watching your hands like
yeah there's like chess with your hands
sorry
exactly that's not gonna happen so yeah
who knows like I mean if we had to make
a bad drug legal the worst choice was
alcohol it's definitely the case you
know what I'm saying that as somewhat of
a fan of alcohol me too
yeah I like it it's but if it's a bad
drug and is it also starting to become
archaic as we get into drugs that are
you know like uh you know people are
using psychedelics some more where
people are a little bit curious about
drugs that make you think instead of
instead of drugs that make you not think
right yeah right yeah yeah because
alcohol is kind of an escape into well
it's not full unconsciousness although
it certainly can be yeah but yeah an
alcohol also makes people aggressive
it's the only drug we know that actually
makes people aggressive so and so so you
see a massive effect on crime rates
because half the people who murder
someone are drunk oh yeah and half the
people who are murdered are drunk and
you know and you're most likely to be
murdered by a family member here so I'd
be joking with my audiences is like well
if you really want to get killed the
best thing to do is go drink for the
family which is actually statistically
true which is terribly terribly cold
it's like yeah go get drunk in your
family if you want to die so it's a
typical family I I actually have a
friend or an old friend who killed
someone and he said honestly and this is
a little bit dark but he said it was
awesome huh
right I mean he said it was and this was
a bad person they've been in a fight I
mean you know like but yeah he said it
was there was something and I mean this
guy's obviously pretty affected you know
probably he's kind of caught up in the
dark arts yeah you will you know he's
more you know if you were watching Harry
Potter he's more like slither and then
he is like Gryffindor you know right but
he yeah he said there was something well
it's not like there's no pleasure and
mayhem in destruction right right it's
just perhaps something that should be
replaced by a better pleasure a better
pleasure and I think that that's not
watch it if there's no if there is no
meet to the temptation it would be
irrelevant the darks the dark places
that people go are very tempting yeah
and it's even more complicated than that
because naive people aren't better than
people who are looking at the darkness
mm-hmm right and so's you know the naive
people think oh well everyone should be
naive and these little box isn't all
protected and you know the people who
pop outside of that and engage a bit
with the darker things they think well
you know Eve people you're just naive
it's like yeah naive first cynical
second wise third you want to get
through cynicism and darkness to wisdom
as fast as you possibly can and you
should know that that's a place to go
right just like you were saying a minute
ago it's like you need to have you need
to know that there are places to go
where you are ya always are and they
have to be real and not naive you
nothing well why should I be good it's
like well maybe you shouldn't it's good
it's just I Eve but you know people the
really good people aren't naive they're
tough as they're tough as they can
possibly be and they've seen things it's
men they decided to become good its
steadfast I mean you have to you have to
I'm realizing that I have to daily show
up for myself if I want my life to be
what I want it ready right it is a
battle and not only that but it's like
you have to you have to have some sort
of a plane when I used to be a little
bit more aimless I was just like I want
things to be good it wasn't enough
no no because things don't know how to
you good this is true all bye left to
themselves things go from bad to worse
things yeah things things oh yeah yes as
entropy like leave your house alone for
a year
yeah see what happens oh it's way better
it's like no it's not it has black mold
everywhere right and the vandalism ou've
din there's graffiti everywhere and yeah
the squirrels are on a pentagram like
things have gotten out of hand
haki that's definitely not good but not
happening excuse this quick interruption
I got to tell you about
bird dogs bird dogs are shorts but they
have underwear built into them think
about that think about the fact that
sometimes you wear shorts and underwear
at the same time and think about how
crazy that is
think about it think about running
around with two two pieces of clothing
wrapped around your jump that's a thing
of the past man you might end up you
could end up as a hitchhiker if you're
behaving like that you could end up in a
mental health facility as a patient or
at least as an outpatient there's no
reason to still be wearing underwear
inside of your shorts you know you might
as well just go live with the dinosaurs
so bird dogs has these new beautiful
hitters right here and with things you
can do anything you want in here you can
get inside of there with your whole body
instead of pants instead of wearing
pants at the pool now you can wear
shorts at the pool like a regular
gladiator bird dogs are the way to go
nobody likes a guy who still wears
underwear that guy can't dance that guy
usually has matches on him that guy has
adult asthma but he's lying about it and
he just says that he whistles a lot with
his lungs it's just so old so it's just
so old school
so go to bird dogs dot-com and use promo
code Vaughn vo in and they'll throw in a
free dad hat are you a dad or do you
want to be well now you got the hat for
it they say it's a $50 value for that
hat
go to bird dogs dot-com you will not
take these things off I promise you can
live in these and you can die in these
bird dogs calm promo code Vaughn and now
back to the episode with mr. Jordan B
Peterson I have one question then we
need to sing questions from our
listeners so like I feel like it's like
you know I grew up in a poor white
environment you know and now I've been
fortunate enough I really look at it as
fortunate to get out of that environment
and be able to see what life is like and
almost from a different perspective you
know like like we don't have the same
problems the same judgments and stuff
here in Los Angeles as we did in
Louisiana when I was growing up it's
just not part of the nature yeah you
know but I see a huge one of the biggest
issues I notice and it's very obvious to
me is this that people's
of especially in America are so
different it's like of course here in
Los Angeles like you know you know we're
in Beverly Hills or you would never like
want to have a gun you know it just
seems silly and be like where you even
put it like right you know it would it
would make your pants look on right it
would you know they're tight which is
most of the pants exactly but where I'm
from like in a you would all you would
certainly have a gun you might not have
it on you but you would have one for
safety but it's just like it's it's
interesting how the two sides can't see
how the other one would make sense you
know yeah this is a crazy perspective
issue and I start to wonder if in the
future through like virtual reality and
stuff like that do you think we'll ever
have like an emotional virtual reality
that can show us not only visually kind
of what someone else's and it doesn't
have to be specifically about the gun
thing but what someone else is wrong we
do have that to some degree you get that
in a movie you know when you go and you
see a character very different than your
work of fiction that's actually why we
use those technologies is so that we can
put ourselves in other people's places
and that does work you know it is an
effective technology and it's hard to
say to what degree virtual reality might
augment that right but we're very
curious about such things and you can be
sure that if we can have a more real
experience using virtual reality than we
can with a movie we'll definitely do it
we're we're majorly into simulations of
alternate realities and it's partly
because well look you know you know you
were you grew up in Louisiana and here
and now you're here so you've hit these
different worlds and that's expanded
your perspective it's made you more than
you were yes well in immersing yourself
in fiction is one way of having that
happen right but the more you can do
that the better and and I think your
comments on these cultural differences
are absolutely right I mean the United
States is an unbelievably diverse place
I mean you guys have 300 million people
here that's a lot of people and there
are a lot of different cultural contexts
and there are different rules that go
along with all of them and the gun thing
is really one of them I mean I come from
this little town in northern Alberta
most people there have a gun or ten or a
hundred like they have lots of guns yeah
I hunt you know I grew up on wild meet
my dad hunts he still hunts he's 82 you
know he's slowing down a little
obviously because he's getting old but
yeah he's using a gun now instead of a
knife yeah jump on the animals yeah so
yes and and but and and people don't
necessarily understand unless they've
been beat around a little bit how
different these different contexts are
and that there can be valid rules that
apply in the different contexts you know
and it's best to live and let live as
far as I'm concerned and yeah I also
don't think that only the state should
be allowed to be dangerous which is
partly why I don't really like the
restrictions I mean some reasonable
restrictions on weapon ownership are
obviously necessary you don't get to
have a Sherman tank rights you're a
private collector you know probably you
shouldn't have an atom bomb something
like that and so there's some cutoff to
how heavily you should be armed agree
but zero zero amount of dangerousness is
the wrong amount of dangerousness for
the for the for the autonomous citizen
yeah I think people should be encouraged
in some sense to be as dangerous as they
can be and still be civilized that's a
great motif well I think for women and
men yeah for both it's like yeah man you
should be dangerous it's like no you
should be nice it's like nice night the
distinction between nice and weak is
very very difficult to make know if
you're a horrible monster and you've got
that developed and you can be civilized
and decent like more power to it's one
thing I really like about Joe Rogan you
know he's an absolute bloody monster
he's really really really tough yeah
and yet he's very truthful he's very
forthright like and all that toughness
is integrated into his character and it
makes him a formidable interviewer
because you can tell like he won't budge
no not a bit he also extraordinarily
funny so he's it's cool to see him
mm-hmm I think he really is a remarkable
person and I've watched lots of people
yes he's like four standard deviations
above the mean and tough he's four
standard deviations above the mean in
smart and he's four standard deviations
above the mean and funny yeah that's a
hell of a good man he's like to me he's
like a point and he's also a father of
three girls which I drink Carmical it's
so confidence did you see his take on
the Kardashians huh oh my god it's in
his last comedy special and he talks
about oh wait yeah you know I've seen
that on stage dominated by women which
he is at the moment so
carmical he's like a poignant teddy bear
that joined the Marines
well charcoal will wink is kind of like
that to it I haven't met him jock was
about 6 inches thicker is he's really
and he's a formidable looking guy yeah
no doubt about it and he's like
discipline yourself the hell out of bed
in the morning a bloody weasel and you
know what yourself together so much of
that is so much of that is even the
things that I learned in a a is just
getting going like alter contrary action
take the next right action whatever it
is no matter how I feel even if I feel
like I'm a piece of [ __ ] or I'm not
worth something or that nobody loves me
or that nobody ever loved me yeah like
no matter what all true is always gonna
see how one loves you yeah probably true
but get up and you take that and make my
[ __ ] bed because then once I do that
I'm gonna go to the next thing and then
suddenly I'm suddenly I'm in the living
room and I maybe you know maybe there's
an egg grilling in the other room and
I'm suddenly in control of my life and
my feelings and my negative thoughts
aren't in control anymore take that take
the take the best next step that you can
manage to take yeah that's a great rule
man and you'll that's the right path hey
and that's the question well if you're
because it's forward forward it's a
forward toward something worthwhile
that's where you want to be you want to
be moving forward towards something
worthwhile you don't even necessarily
want to be where it's worthwhile
although that would be alright and maybe
now and then you get there and then
you're happy but mostly what you want to
be is moving forward to something
worthwhile which also indicates why you
need to specify something worthwhile
think well what's worthwhile that's up
to you what will get you out of the bed
in the morning and a miserable day what
would be worthwhile and one of the
things I've been talking to my audiences
about a lot when they're responding to
this great and I think this is a really
important thing to know almost
everything that you do that will be
meaningful will involve the adoption of
responsibility interestingly enough
because people think well vacation
impulsive pleasure cocaine alcohol you
know the hey hedonism essentially that's
what makes life worthwhile it's like no
that's not right like there's there's a
place for hedonic pleasure man for sure
although you got to be careful of it you
got because it's it's it's a trap right
well alcohol cocaine very even the bus
they haven't have two pieces of key lime
pie I feel like
I've gone this Dante semicircle you know
what I'm saying like so I feel you there
you know but yeah there is a place in
time yeah well so but most of the time
what gets you out of bed is the fact
that you're doing something that's
worthwhile you taking care of yourself a
little bit at least moving yourself
forward and maybe you're moving your
family forward doing something for
someone else at least and maybe if you
really got your act together you're
doing something for the community right
and so you need a meaning to set off to
set against the tragedy of existence and
the malevolence of existence for that
matter and the meaning is mostly to be
found in the adoption of
responsibilities and so that's so
interesting because it's not obvious
right it doesn't seem like it oh I take
no more I'm already overwhelmed but
you're not overwhelmed you're just
stagnant you're just stuck and you just
or maybe that's not you're not just
stagnant but you're just you can do it
and the reward is gonna be there you
just might not see it it doesn't feel
that way
well it'll feel that way a little bit at
3:00 in the morning you think well what
did I do to justify my wretched
existence you can say well at least like
least I got out of bed and I cleaned my
room a little bit and you know maybe I
did something for my daughter you had a
complete waste of space right you know
and no one can live with that kind of
shame and guilt it just takes you out
and that's what takes you into other
things like drugs and alcohol that's for
sure excuses they look as then you feel
a little bit more justified it gives you
like oh well I'm not just a bad parent I
have an addiction or I have this from
you yeah and you can use it as a
temporary escape you know yeah yeah well
and sometimes people also you know
they're genuinely depressed or they're
genuinely anxious and and the medication
actually does help and that's also you
know positive and negative negative
insofar as it produces a trap and why
are so many men aimless right now why
are so many men right now like bar
because they're actually not encouraged
like I'm stunned and I think this is
what parents can't parent anymore it's
like that you know it's like I know I
heard you and Joe talking about like um
you know nobody you know the baseball
games are all you know the softball
games that everybody wins
yeah but then a parent does that was a
stupid game Miss Judy wins but here's
you can't win if everybody wins right no
one won no one won but also no parent
gets to have the conversation like oh
you lost and this is okay or no parent
gets to have that conversation like oh
you won don't be a sore winner
yeah well it
the conversation is oh you lost but that
doesn't mean you're a loser right right
that's the important conversation Opare
n't but that conversation not even
happening on if you're not if you don't
have the opportunity to lose right so
parents aren't there's no reprimanding
from the parents there's no connection
there with like um you know if
everybody's a winner then there's no you
you don't need your parent to you know
move you back into a comfortable space
you know when you get off you know you
don't get to tell your son oh hell
what's a loss to a great kid like you
yeah you know like that next game yeah
for it yeah there's no like you put your
seer armor on your son's neck after he's
lost and he feels that it's a good game
yeah good game and that before you say
look you know that looked a little rough
anything you think you could do better
next time yeah well what can we do
better yeah let's get out we'll duel try
it tomorrow yeah yeah but that kind of
stuff those moments I feel like are the
moments that build especially young men
and live inside of them well it's
inverse so one of the things that's that
I find quite painful is all these people
that I'm encountering I think it's more
true for young men because I think young
women are getting more encouragement
from society all things considered and
maybe not maybe that's not right but
doesn't matter it's still the case that
lots of young men come and talk to me
and it's obvious that no one has ever
encouraged them yeah and I mean
encouraged technically no one has
attempted to instill courage into them
yes to say look man you're worthwhile
you're worth what you're worth while no
there's something in you that could
develop into something great that's sort
of like the right definition of
worthwhile it's not like you're okay the
way you are like no you're not what and
why would I ever say that because what
okay you're just fine well great you
might as well just like take take ambien
and become unconscious because you got
nothing else to do yeah like no there's
plenty for you to do to put yourself
together but you're the sort of person
who could do it you could put yourself
together you could be more than you are
and you should be because otherwise the
world he generates into hell yeah that's
exactly what happens it's like and it's
it's so sad in some sense for me to see
how little encouragement people actually
need because there's lots of people
coming to talk to me and they say well
you know I haven't had a farther
there was no male influence in my life
for no one
no-one's ever all that's basically yet
they haven't had that kind of
encouraging influence and so no one's
ever said these things to them and so
someone says something to them they go
oh really that's the possibility and
then they go out and like fix things it
didn't take much
didn't take much no it didn't take much
now do you feel like there's special
gifts you have because I was thinking
about this I was like well why does
Jordan get through to people like and
for one I was thinking like your voice
you have a like if you don't know you if
you've never seen a picture of you you
could be 27 or 140 I feeling like you
could own your time you have a timeless
voice that's what I mean more you have a
voice I feel like that I could have
heard an 18-10 or a voice that I could
hear thirty years from now like it's
almost like it doesn't fit in so it's
almost you can reach so many more if the
if the sound wave is like a wave that
everybody can adapt to do you feel
anything like that or is that just I
think it's an interesting observation I
mean give this Norman Rockwell e-type of
it that's how it comes into this is me
speaking yeah me but I'm noticing the
way it affects other men like you know
what people have said that you know that
I've got this kind of old-fashioned
appearance in a sense yeah yeah and just
my voice but just yeah like you just
came on a train and the train just came
out of nowhere like oh you know this
guy's selling some you know there's some
beautiful snake oil salesmen it's like
well no not exactly no this is sibility
snake oil agreed agreed snake oil I
think the opposite of it's the opposite
yeah you've got problems cuz you have
things to do yeah it's funny cuz I've
been you know talking to young men to
its boat about the ones that get all
resentful about being rejected by women
or all the women are rejecting you a
it's like yeah those goddamn women it's
like no if all the women are rejecting
you it's not the women but that's you to
do it's all of them mmm voted down
pretty heavy there and you might think
well that's crushing it's like yeah no
kidding yeah but but the positive end of
the message is there's lots of things
you could do to fix it and you could
start small and it would fix it and it
will work yeah so do you think no it's
hopeless it's like no it's not it's not
hopeless things aren't hopeless yeah
that's right things aren't hope
well they certainly aren't hopeless if
you can see things you're doing that
you're that are making things worse
sit down take stock your life you think
okay what am i doing to make things
worse you have to ask yourself that
question like and you have to ask and
you have to write the answers yes yes
that would be good you also have to want
the answers and you won't because the
answers are gonna hurt right because
they are the things you're doing to make
things worse
what am i doing to make myself weaker
and stupider than I have to be sit on
the edge of your bed that's like a
prayer if you want to have a prayer
there's one why am i weak and stupid man
you'll get lots answers to that question
it's like well that's so hopeless it's
like no if you go to buy a house and you
don't have very much money you buy a
wreck of a house and you don't pretend
that the house is any better than it is
right not unless you're willfully blind
looking for trouble you think no no this
place a it's all I can afford and be
well I can fix it right well you can you
can fix it but not unless you know where
the where everything's broken so you
think well why am i taking stock of
where everything's broken there's
nothing I can do about its like aim
lower
there's something you could fix right
something about you you could fix today
you think well that's so trivial it's
not worth doing it's like no if it's
moving you ahead a little bit you'll be
slightly better tomorrow than you were
today and then maybe you can chew off a
little bigger chunk yeah and you'll be a
little tiny bit better the next day and
then you can chew off a bigger chunk and
now that'll speed you along like
nobody's business and other things the
little chunks that you chew they're
gonna magnify quickly yeah by creating
other responsibilities you won't even
notice you're doing it like an example
would be say if there's um you know
something in your place I covered or
something that's covered with newspapers
or junk or whatever you move it off you
put a plant there yeah right so now
you've cleaned off your cover you have a
plant now the plants gonna need water
each day yeah so next thing you know now
you're taking care of something you
stayin yes it's just it's interesting
right how quickly these things multiple
absolutely well that's why well it's so
funny too because I've been telling to
be able to clean up their room it's like
God it's not like everybody hasn't heard
that fifty thousand times yeah it's
become this meme but the reason for that
is because I tried to explain to people
to everyone including me why it's
important to clean up your rooms like
hey man you have a room yeah it's like
most people throughout human history
have not had a room you have a room on
my rooms a hellhole it's like well then
you're a denizen of Hell inhabiting it
you should do something about that well
what well put it in minimal order get
your clothes together because you have
to wear those and that some people that
people are looking at your clothes so
get your clothes in order what clothes
should you be wearing not the clothes of
a total wretched loser how about you
know Tasmanian Devils and stuff like
that right exactly well and what about
your bed well is it comfortable do you
make it in the morning so it looks like
half civilized can you sleep there it's
like is is there junk everywhere so you
just hate your life when you walk into
your room it's like clean the damn thing
up yes you can do it
order your drawers learn to fold your
clothes you could probably learn that
put it in minimal order and then man you
could get spectacular oh you said put a
plant in there it's like a plant well
then you have to learn how plants work
and then you have to water the damn
thing but then there's something living
in your room you might hope my room is
the sort of place where something could
hypothetically live like yeah yeah like
you exactly and then you might actually
start to live well you might you might
if you set the stage for it you might
start to play the part in anything wow
that's it
maybe I could make it beautiful it's
like then not only would you have a room
if you want to get opposition from
people around you who aren't happy about
you trying to improve things
cleaning might not do it although it
might because people think who the hell
do you think you are cleaning up your
room it's like you know yeah are you
better than me
it's like oh maybe maybe maybe for a
second maybe you think you can think you
are maybe man maybe you know if you're
if you're maybe that's your brother your
older brother or your father he's all
covered with Cheetos dust and his guts
hanging out he's watching TV smoking a
cigarette thing oh you think you're
better than me eh it's like well yeah
there's gonna be resistance but you
that'll be nothing like the resistance
you'll get if you try to start making
your room beautiful man that'll produce
resistance because beauty is absolutely
terrifying to people because beauty
beauty highlights what's ugly and so if
you start to make your room beautiful
that everything
that isn't like that just starts to glow
mean like in in the in the in the worst
sense so is that dangerous then oh yes
that's terribly dangerous that's why
people are afraid of beauty but it's the
greatest thing you can do because it
puts you in alignment with like
beautiful things are beautiful for a
reason right that beauty has depth like
it's real depth man that that's what
gets you in touch with the transcendent
and the divine isn't beauty you
introduce that into your room you're
playing with fire and people will resist
it and so you can think well first of
all I'll make my room Spartan and clean
and neat sort of like military level
discipline like clean it's like okay now
you got it cleaned up and then you think
my clothes are in order I got it cleaned
up now now maybe I'll try to I'll do
something that'll make it beautiful well
then you have to learn what beauty is
too and that's really hard nuts and
that'll be scared that's gonna be scary
because if you're a dude you can't yeah
well you're also gonna think well what
the hell do I know I have terrible taste
we'd like undoubtedly true yeah so do
your best you know get a print of
something get a print of a great
painting put it on your rooms like you
think oh I don't know what they all that
thing's doing there it's like look out
man that thing's got power
so look think about it this is I was in
this museum a while back in New York and
it was I don't remember which museum it
was in but it was full of these
paintings from the late Renaissance and
so they were there was like a dozen of
them in this one room and and like by
people like Michelangelo Rodin stuff
like that Rodin would be later but the
same caliber or caliber of artists same
caliber and so I was in that room and
that's like every painting on that wall
was worth 300 million dollars like
minimum you couldn't buy those paintings
like they're priceless but if they were
ever went for market it'd be that's
about what they'd be worth it was like a
dozen of them in there I thought wow
there's like 3.6 billion dollars worth
of paintings in this room and then
there's people all over the world
they're coming to look at these
paintings and you think okay look here
we are we're in the richest city in the
world prime low prior ill estate in this
unbelievably expensive museum in this
sealed room the paintings are worth 3.6
billion dollars and people are making
pilgrimages from all over the world just
to look at them it's like what the
hell's going on it's like yeah no
kidding what the hell's going on there's
beauty in those paintings there's beauty
and it's magnificent and part
what it does is say you aren't who you
should be that's what Beauty does to you
it's like you aren't that's why you're
intimidated by a beautiful woman a
staggeringly beautiful woman it's like
oh my god
you know attracted for sure but
definitely intimidates coz you aren't
who you could be beauty does that to you
because I sew up because I'm not who I
could be mm-hmm yeah well because Beauty
has that contrast it's like oh cuz oh
wow there that beautiful then it
suddenly look what I am look Who I am
yeah that's when you need a drink yeah
like 10 of them that's easy yeah that's
what you need to read it that's how you
need to relax
right let's get into a couple of
questions that we have from some callers
if you don't mind you're it thank you so
much man this will be a familiar voice
to our listeners a feel and open dr.
Peterson as well this is trick lung
Nicky and I had a question to you both
about self-awareness it's an aspect of
life that they're all pretty big
advocate for and I find that more often
than not people are acting without much
of it without a strong conscious thought
before a lot of their actions so I'd
like to hear you guys as insight on how
to reach this subject to a loved one
tactfully you know what's a way dr.
Peterson that I could maybe assist in a
loved ones like their growth in this
manner without seemingly being arrogant
or holier than thou as well that's good
well that's how humans you guys thought
both of your guys thoughts on this and
Mickey's a guy he he just got a lung
transplant he's kind of like been a mask
out of the podcast over the past year
I'm he had cystic fibrosis and he's got
a couple of new airbags so he's you know
that's the best I've ever heard him talk
so he's using them no good well Jesus
that's a hell of a thing but that's a
big question yeah if you have some you
know like people are moving without
thought now people are it's like if you
have information just on your phone it
means you have it inside of your head
and then people are making you know
people are moving or just so you you you
obviously have a specific example in
mind and so imagine that you're
interacting with someone who who is
wandering down a kind of blind path and
you want to broach it and so the first
issue is you kind of got to get the
moral superiority
you're out of your own tone right
because you're not lording it over them
because that's not going to go very well
right and then maybe you need to collect
a few examples you know so before you
say confront the person or have the
discussion you could say well look I
noticed this and it didn't go very well
and I didn't say anything about it and
then I noticed this which was another
example of the same thing and I still
didn't say anything about it and then I
noticed this and it was the third thing
and like all three of those things
happened and they didn't have very good
consequences and I'm kind of wondering
what do you think about that like do you
think that's working out for you is
there something that might be done about
it mind just being stupid here and it's
good to have a genuine question about it
and so you can sometimes you can and you
want to make it also the other thing is
you want to make it about as little as
possible because you don't want to just
wall up the person yeah you know when
you want to tap them on the side of the
head you don't hit them with a
sledgehammer and so if you're trying to
initiate a productive dialogue you got
to have your evidence in in order and
you have to make that that conversation
about something small enough so it isn't
gonna destroy the person to confront
something like that
right yeah if you go too hard on
somebody there it's gonna be ineffective
they're just gonna fight yeah I'm gonna
say tail with you you're just a son of a
[ __ ] or maybe they'll burst into tears
and they'll get angry or they'll stop
the conversation and even fold yourself
into it if you can well that would be
good yeah you know you can say well
here's here's here's how I'm
contributing to the idiocy it's really
useful if you're dealing with someone
like like your wife or a close intimate
partner yeah it's like I noticed we're
in this pathway this has happened two or
three times here's how I think I'm
contributing right and that has to be
real yeah take your own tea yes show
your own because we all have a part in
it you have a part in everything hmm so
show what your part is yes and yes well
and then you can also if you actually
discover what your part is then you can
maybe stop playing that part you know
like if I I've learned that if I'm
embroiled in a in a dispute with my wife
you know and there's reasons for
disputes you have complicated problems
to solve and you're different so that's
why there are disputes apart from your
own stupidity and malevolence and all of
that but there are real reasons to have
disputes so maybe you're in a dispute
and you can't get out of it and you're
trying to show you're right and it's not
going anywhere and you think okay we
better break apart because it's going
sideways if you go into a
room and you sit again on the edge of
your bed or a chair and you think okay
probably I've done something stupid to
contribute to this in some way what
might it have been and if you ask like
you want the answer you'll get the
answer and it won't be an answer you
like and it won't be something you like
to admit you might think well it's only
5% my fault still it's like yeah okay
but at least it's 5% then you can go
back to your wife and you could say
here's the stupid thing I've done to
contribute to this and I figured it out
and I'll try not to do it again and you
know sorry I'm so dumb yeah and maybe if
she's done the same thing she can tell
you the same thing
and then maybe now you're both like
humbled a bit in the proper way you can
actually have a discussion that's aimed
at solving the problem instead of
attaining victory yeah why do we have to
be right like like I don't have to be I
hope to not have to be right a lot of
time I'm happy to be wrong hmm
like we yeah for some does this thing
out there these days that everyone they
just have to be right there's no
discussion anymore better learn
something than to be right unless you're
already right enough and if you think
you're right enough well look if your
life is perfect and everything's exactly
the way you want it to be you're right
enough man good for you yeah I've met
anybody like that yet and especially
when you are commingling with others
that's when you have to uh you know
sometimes you have to not be right just
for everybody one thing that's worth
thinking about Nightline this a fair bit
in this book 12 rules for life is like
do you want to make friends with what
you know or do you want to make friends
with what you don't know and so so you
might because it's a good questions like
well what I know that's all secure and
and it's easy let's say it's easy it's
fortified and it's worked it's like yeah
fine but it's insufficient or unless
everything's perfect which it isn't so
it's insufficient it's like okay well if
you make friends with what you don't
know and then you have a discussion with
someone and they tell you something you
don't know then you have the opportunity
to be a little bit smarter and if you're
trying to avoid hell let's say it it
it's useful to be a little bit smart a
little wiser and so even if you're
having an acrimonious argument with
someone you know maybe you can sift a
little
of wheat from the chaff and you can
think yeah well most of what you're
saying it's nonsense but you know that
one point you made there it's like that
pointed that's a point you made a point
it pointed me somewhere maybe somewhere
slightly more value but I learned
something it's also why it's so useful
to talk to people that don't agree with
you mm-hmm
it's like of course they're wrong they
don't agree with you yeah well but maybe
you're wrong about something
and so right people are and they people
want to feel just appreciate it even if
they even if you don't agree with them
sometimes it's at least appreciating
that they are presenting just listening
yes well Carl Rogers had real useful
he's a psychotherapist he had a real
useful piece of advice about that
it's one of the rare pieces of advice
that I think actually work in
psychotherapy cuz mostly that's about
suggestion people discover what they
need to do they have to discover it you
facilitate that right Roger said look if
you're having an argument with someone
this really works if it's someone close
to you it's like you're having this
bitter argument it's like here's the
rule you have your say then I am going
to say what you told me but you have to
agree that I got it right mmm right and
then and then the reverse I get to have
my piece and then you get to say what I
said you don't have to agree that's not
the point
but you have to formulate my argument
back to me in a manner that I agree with
and so you're gonna reduce it to the
gist and realize you're not gonna treat
me like an imbecile or a straw man right
and one of the things Rogers pointed out
is if you do that the arguments tend to
become productive mmm so that's a love
that's a lovely technique it really does
work because immediately you are you're
recognizing what they're saying you're
at least less well and you're at least
listening listening to is if you listen
to someone sometimes if you listen to
someone they discover the limits of
their own argument they think oh so they
lay it out and they think oh well I'm
really not as mad about that as I
thought or oh that isn't exactly what I
meant or or maybe there's something else
going on here that I didn't understand
like if you let them lay out the whole
thing and you just shut up while they
stumble around then sometimes they
stumble somewhere slightly more
productive and that's also useful that's
also I think this is something that
happens between men and women a lot so a
woman will be upset about something and
she'll come and tell her husband about
it and he'll try to solve the problems
like yes now and you think well the
problem needs to be
salsa way why isn't that okay for her
and the answer is she hasn't fully
formulated the problem so you have to
wait
well she stumbles around not that women
do that anymore than men that's not my
point
well she stumbles around says well
here's why I think I'm upset here's one
possibility here's another possibility
here's another possibility you might
have to listen to ten possibilities
before the actual problem emerges
because it's not like people always know
why they're upset right sometimes they
especially this upset into at the moment
yeah and then maybe something triggered
it at work yesterday and they did you
know their boss said something rude and
they've been kind of stewing on that all
day and that's made them irritable and
then they snap at something trivial you
think well what the hell's wrong with
you
the person says what here's what it is
you listen and you think well and then
they stumble around and they think oh um
there's something else that's still
bothering me and it's like it takes a
bunch of digging to get to the bottom so
you have to shut up and let that happen
and then maybe you can think okay how
can we solve this problem but if you
jump in there too early you circumvent
the process of exploration you can't
solve a problem unless you formulate it
properly and that's one of the things
that I think is so rough these days in
an hour especially in the US I find
especially like in like in the
mainstream it's like there's no
discussion there's just like yeah well
these long-form conversations are
changing they're changing that and maybe
pretty fast too yeah oh I look I'm so
fast in it there were times when I'm
like damn am I ever gonna be able to
have any sort of career in this world
that I want to have a career in and then
but then I see like a lot of like these
yeah regular television shows people
just don't but there's no authenticity
in them anymore because I'd rather watch
somebody be wrong at least if they're
trying to be yes yes absolutely
well that's good because that's life
right people people being wrong while
they're trying to be that's life so if I
don't find that engaging there's real
trouble to be had and it just shuts
people down it's like you know if I
can't say if I like there's so many
accusations are racism stuff these days
now say if I feel like there's racism in
me right somewhere inside of me yeah and
whether it was you know who knows where
I could have learned it from yeah who
knows if some of it is justifiable in
the sense
that a race was violent towards me or
you did something towards me that made
me or someone of a race did something
you know but it's like if I if it's like
there's these people these today they
just want me to sign a piece of paper
that would be like oh at one time I was
racist or I promise I'll never be racist
but whatever that is it doesn't help me
solve whatever it doesn't help me get to
whatever if there is any discomfort in
me about any about race even about my
own race it doesn't help me get to that
well if you don't let people be wrong
and stupid you can't let them be at all
yeah you know and that's actually the
huge part of the reason for free speech
it's like we have to stumble along
around like morons to to stumble upon
the truth you're gonna say stupid things
we're gonna stay say wrong things yeah
that's why I wasn't costly speech book
if we needed to make it free because
we're gonna [ __ ] it up so much yeah like
it was like it's gotta be free right cuz
we're gonna use so much figure out where
we're going yeah exactly that's right if
there was a cost yeah if it would be way
too high good point man that's a nice
way of thinking about it but yeah I you
know and that's one thing that I you
there's something you have a gift and I
don't know if it's a learned one or if
you feel like it's just something from
you know a higher power that you're a
conduit for this that you don't sound
too much you sound like a no it's um but
you don't sound like a no at all I
always in myself in my in the audience
that I'm speaking to like maybe you need
improvement we it's that we need
improved in yeah and I'm in there man
I've got a group of people who could use
some radical improvement and you believe
that no definitely yeah absolutely
look I mean yeah so do I like five
sometimes I'm just talking just to just
because i'm hoping somewhere in all of
it I'll help myself
mm-hmm you know or that when someone
calls that I'll you know like it's crazy
how many callers calling with the
thoughts and feelings and stuff like
that and it makes it it shows me
something that I never knew and you
might get that probably in questions
that people ask you one look I mean I'm
not as tough as I could be I'm not as
smart as I could be I'm not as musically
gifted as I could be like I haven't read
as much as I could read I don't know
enough about history like there's
endless numbers of things that I could
be doing better right
yeah well I'd like to do them better but
they're endless so right I'm trying to
keep my eyes open and figure out okay
what can I do better and the world would
be a better place if I was a better
person so I'm gonna try to be a better
person and so I'm trying to figure that
out because it's important I'm in the
conversation man yeah so and I think the
people that that people that are
engaging to talk to an often in these
long-form discussions it's the same
thing as they're in there in the
audience of people who need to be
improved yeah so at least when the
dialogue is going well you know and so
when I hear like the last caller and he
comes up with a question like that's
like yeah that's a real question man
that's like something to grapple with so
I like that I like that man yeah
they say you know this is tower I live
in Tennessee not a question for Jordan
Pederson Jordan when you look back on
your life in your older what do you
think your most important contribution
will be and I don't mean the things that
you have done but things you may plan on
doing and I really appreciate you doing
this all on and having me on so thanks
guys and thank you Jordan bye well I
think establishing this link between
responsibility and meaning is a good
thing and I've outlined that a fair bit
in the first book I wrote which was maps
of meaning the audio version of that is
available now by the way and it's a it's
a very hard book but I think the audio
version is comprehensible
so so if you like 12 rules for life you
and you want to dig deeper that's a good
place to dig and the tests I took last
night will help as well yeah yeah that's
another thing we didn't that we didn't
talk about I have this test online
called understand myself calm which I
would recommend it it'll give you a
description of your personality
according to a Big Five model
extraversion neuroticism which is
sensitivity to negative emotion
agreeableness conscientiousness and
openness and then it breaks each of
those down into two sub traits and so I
would say it's really useful for you to
do that find out where your strengths
and weaknesses are what your character
is but it's also really useful to have
the people around you do it because
you'll you'll find out there are things
about them you do
know things you like like one of the
things with my father could never
understand my father because in some
ways because it was hard to get him to
be kind of what would you say
enthusiastic about about about adventure
something like that he wasn't an
enthusiastic person idea wasn't you know
I was going well he was he was in a
sense while he did the test anyways and
extraversion splits into assertiveness
and enthusiasm he's really low in
enthusiasm but he's hiding assertiveness
oh I see he's assertive he can put
himself forward he's four three likes to
hunt but he's not he's not a giggly
enthusiastic person it's just not in his
temperament I thought oh that's
interesting that was really useful do
you feel like you turned it in that same
way or no no I'm enthusiastic yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm quite enthusiastic
and I was watching like my mother in
that regard yeah so do you find is it
neat to be like your mother a little bit
well my mother's a really good person
like she was she she was the thing I
really liked about my mother one thing
is that I could always make her laugh so
we shared that you know and so she
thought I had a good sense of humor and
I used it a lot around her and so that
was really good but she she was also
100% behind me was great and she was my
mother's a nice person you know she's an
agreeable person she's a caring person
but she's got a spine man and she didn't
mall or water her kids oh yes she's also
a very hard worker so yeah she had that
right like she she would take care of us
and she was on our side but she she
threw us out in the world and she didn't
interfere so and and I could see that's
one of your steps in your book isn't it
that they there has to be a little bit
of danger when when kids playing oh yeah
is a twelfth step I think yeah yeah oh
don't bother children in the
skateboarding yes yeah cuz they that's
right because if you're gonna make your
kids tough which they better be if
they're gonna survive in the world then
then you can't interfere when they're
doing dangerous things carefully hmmmm
and maybe not even that carefully right
no but still even in that were to think
about it that specifically dangerous
things carefully that's such a place
where kids learn oh yeah that is the
only place they learn that's where
everyone learns everything when you're
doing dangerous things carefully man
that's where you learn and so what you
interfere with that you interfere with
the process by which you children expand
their competence and it takes courage
not to interfere with that when you see
your three-year-old daughter climbing up
the monkey bars our daughter used to do
that in our backyard you know and she
was three in the monkey bars were about
eight feet high she liked to go right to
the top and climb across them it's like
we're watching out the back window
thinking but what do you do we you want
around there be careful right which is
the thing uh there's a bit of
malevolence in that oh my daughter is
worrying me I'll go out there and take
care of her about startle her then
she'll fall well that'll fix her she
won't do that again she won't make me
nervous it's like you gotta watch those
things man right it's not about them
it's about you yes that's for sure
that's what you got to ask yourself am i
taking care of my child or am I just
afraid to be afraid for them mm-hmm now
it's no there's no excuse for that we
you talked a minute ago about your
mother laughing and it's so funny I
thought since I got an ax I realized my
mother and I never laughed when I was a
kid you know and I realized I just
realized that once I got an a a like a
lot of thing I started to have a lot
more emotions and thoughts and feelings
and just be able to look at my life
instead of being so stressed out about
my current whatever it is I was able to
let this subside and whatever was in
front of me so I could see forward and
backward a little bit and even just see
into like moments that I had with family
but it's just so fascinating uh when you
said that I was like oh man that was
such a thing and I realized recent ever
got to laugh with that mother too bad
because you're funny yeah so that would
have been great and I think I know but I
think I realized and sorry I interrupted
no problem I think one of the reasons
why I ended up getting into being funny
even against probably my own will was
all I wanted to do was probably make my
mother laugh you know and the fact so I
had to make everybody I don't if I was
afraid to or if we just but we never I
never realized it until I about a year
and a half ago I'm like man my mother
and I have never laughed together and
I'm like that's so sad
it's sad yeah it's sad you better how
come you know I don't know I think she
knows reticular the next time you see
she was a hard worker you know what yeah
there are little things that starts I
start to have little plans when I'm
talking around the phone I'll say I'll
make like a goofy voice or something
just to see cuz we've never done that
yeah you know to think that my mother's
never heard me be goofy yeah or that
I've never heard her step out of you
know whatever you know laughter zones or
something that we built her sighs just
might be interesting to see if you could
make an inroad there now that you've
realized today but it's so powerful and
if there's people out there that have
children then are not having that
experience it's just such a it it lets
it lets a kid know that everything is
kind of okay yeah well that's that's a
big purpose of humor man well you got a
there's a sticker on the computer over
there Funny or Die partly why I took
Dave Rubin ruff long see on the tour oh
yeah
well a little bit of humours it's not a
good thing it's bloody necessary do you
who makes you laugh I mean obviously you
know you just mentioned David who makes
how you left his her comedian over town
oh yeah dude he's a Canadian aphrodisiac
isn't he yeah he's damn funny and so I
like stand-up comedians in general I
liked who's the guy that just got in
trouble in New York Oh Louie CK Louie CK
yeah it's like it's a deviant yeah and
it has a lot of great comedian yes
Marlon Williams Howie Mandel those are
two friends of mine and those are funny
men oh yeah there's lots canadians can
really produce comedians you gotta keep
ourselves entertained when it's 211
somebody better be funny I should the
other thing I that I think that I've
done that's very much worthwhile
oh yeah to get back to sorry well I did
a series of biblical lectures last year
and those were very much worthwhile and
they've got a lot of attention on the
web and I'm definitely going to continue
doing them so I'm starting to to lecture
about Exodus in November and I want to
walk through the whole corpus of
biblical stories and and look at them
from a psychological perspective so I'm
hoping that that will be important
because there's well those are
foundational stories and and if your
foundational stories are ignored then
the foundation shifts and the whole
thing Falls and that's not good so well
and that goes back to even what I think
a lot of men we are connecting with you
even
they they it there's some yeah there's a
foundation or something that is somehow
is missing there is and if some and I'm
trying to put that foundation back and
the foundation is in those stories and
part of those stories are about the fact
that well the world is a battleground of
good and evil
and how exciting is it that it is it's
so much more exciting and I find faith
to be so much more exciting like so what
if what if I'm wrong and there's nothing
I'd rather take a chance yeah yeah yeah
I'd rather take a chance and have some
sort of a relationship with a higher
power you can own as opposed to being
alone well you cannot be alone like look
are there things that you do that are
meaningful and things that are not it's
like yes clearly it's easier to find the
things that aren't meaningful but there
are things you do that are more
meaningful it's like okay how meaningful
can meaningful get hmm well it can get
really meaningful like there's no limit
to the depths of meaning I mean that's
partly what people discover if they play
with psychedelics yeah it's like oh huh
there's a bottomless pit oh you can go
to another universe I remember at one
point in my head it was like knock knock
who's there
us hmm hmm like suddenly there was more
than one voice in my head and ii uh like
it was another it was like awakening a
twin or something you know yeah it's
immense
its immense the levels that I'm learning
you can go to with love and I'm in my
life right now a lot of it is love and
acceptance but I'm guessing that with
faith that's probably things can get
really just just the observation is that
some things are more meaningful than
others it's like okay fine then what's
the what's the ultimately meaningful
thing that's that's a religious pursuit
I want to pursue the ultimately
meaningful thing it's like there there
there are successive approximations to
that just as it's obvious that there are
some things that are more worth pursuing
than others it's like well Arthur well
there better be then because otherwise
why pursue anything if one thing isn't
worth pursuing more than another then
how do you make choices between what you
pursue well you obviously make choices
so you rank order value well what's the
ultimate value that's the religious
question is there an ultimate value it's
like well who knows but you can
successively approximate it
yeah you know when you say well what are
the markers for it love is one beauty is
one truth is one Oh nobility of
character that's another those things
are real and they're more real than
their antagonists yes you know so I
think good is more powerful than evil
and I say that lightly man
I studied evil for like 30 years yeah
man you're like sorry yeah you've been
in the dark arts yeah well that in the
clinical practice you know so I've
looked at the darkest things I could
find and some of them I barely recovered
from you still believe that a thing you
still believe that goes more I really
more that more than I did before I
believe that our capacity to transcend
evil is far more powerful than Apple
even though evil is no bloody joke while
that gave us the world war two it gave
us the Gulag Archipelago and the horrors
of the Soviet Union Communist China and
Cambodia and it's like the horrible
tortures that went along with us the
mass slaughter the malevolence and the
lies all of that it's like yeah man
that's dark the light is brighter than
the dark is dark Wow
not something man cuz the dark is plenty
dark so this is a man I mean you're like
you know you're like the Neal arm is
Amelia Lee you're like Neil Armstrong at
the dark moon you know yeah you've been
out there well it's interesting to to
talk to these audiences because what
when I when I talk with them because you
know I make a case to say look it's no
wonder that that you're you're you're
somewhat adrift and bitter about life
its life is really really hard everyone
dies like it's rough man and there's
gonna be not only do you die there's
gonna be a fair bit of katashi along the
way yeah and some of it really rough and
then it's even worse because you impose
some of that on yourself because you're
malevolent and stupid and you make other
people's lives worse it's like Jesus
dismal harsh despite that despite that
there's more to you than that you can
get out of that you can move away from
it you can fix it and I love that that's
powerful there well that's the thing is
so it's yeah I feel that when you say
that you feel like I'm not just even
listening to you like I'm listening to
you with I feel like there are cells in
my body they're traveling to this side
of my body because they want to hear yes
people are longing to hear
that even though life is painful that it
it is a it's it's worth living like
we're in this thing now where it's like
especially my generation like is this
even worth that what's the point of all
this and you make I think you and I'm
not trying to like you know like you
know smoke your salmon or whatever the
term is that and panadol but it's like
what we use okay yeah you know like but
it's like yeah you make me you make me
feel that that's a that that's real I
believe it the light is stronger that
you believe in us
yeah but it's not it's not just it's not
just wishful thinking and it's not
something it surprised me it surprised
me okay so if I surprise you yeah well
you do you feel then that you are a
conduit for this sort of thing and I'm
not saying like you're a messenger from
but do you because sometimes with my
comedy man I don't write it people are
like you right you're so funny I'm just
a thing I'm a person yes I have some you
know I have some game plan but I
sometimes I just feel like I'm just a
conduit like these aren't my ideas that
I come up with but you've done a ton of
research and so do you feel like well
you kind of open the door to ideas
that's what you do if you're creative
but then you have to edit them and
wrestle with them right you know so
there's some of that okay something okay
some inspiration in some perspiration as
they say hmm you know the darkness issue
it did surprise me because like when
when I wrote maps of meaning which as I
said was my first book I started writing
that in 1985 and I picked the worst
problem I could think of to solve the
worst thing and it had to do with what
happened in Norwich there was something
that happened in our wits it was a
variety of this problem so people were
packed into cattle cars and shipped to
Auschwitz and that was rough man like
they were packed into the cattle car so
if it was winter the people around the
edges froze to death right they froze
and if it was summer the people in the
middle died because they got too hot
right it was horrible huh right it was
horrible and then they were taken to
these concentration camps right and then
the concentration camps of course had
they had the gas chambers and yes it
visit and one of oh yes yes enum right
and so one of the things the guards used
to do is they take the prisoners off the
cars and it's not like they hadn't
already
tortured quite nicely and we're already
headed for death and so it's already
pretty much as bad as it could get but
oh no that wasn't bad enough so one of
the tricks the guards used to play was
they'd get the prisoners who could still
more or less move to carry a sack of wet
salt from one side of the compound to
the other it's like when you think well
that's not so bad it's like yeah it's
bad those were the size of cities this
was a major journey and it was a hundred
pound sack of wet salt and especially
when your pores whether you're hurt yeah
yeah it's open about it then they would
have them carry it back you see that's
the little twist there it's like well
it's one thing if you're a guard in this
and the damn salt needs to be moved and
you're just the slave owner whip and the
whip but at least the salt has to be
moved the wall has to be built there's
something in it something there's
something in it carry that there and now
carry it back it's like okay so that
wasn't the question I was trying to
solve the question is what would I have
to be like to do that and enjoy it hmm
right because the people there were
people who did that and they were people
and they enjoyed it and there were a lot
of them right and there were a lot of
them yes and they weren't so different
from you than you think
Wow so that's the thing that I was
trying to figure out I was like what the
hell's at the bottom of that well that's
that was the darkest places I could find
to look there's this story this is a
story of king arthur and the knights of
the round table so they're off to look
for the Holy Grail
who's the the container of the redeeming
substance so it's it's value itself it's
the ultimate value well they don't know
where to go look for the holy it's the
it's the cup that held Christ's blood
from the cross or maybe the cover that
he drank at the last an Indiana Jones
yeah that's right of course and then the
Holy Grail is a very very old idea and
it stands for the ultimate value where
do you go to look for the ultimate value
well the answer in the story of King
Arthur and the Holy Grail is all the
Knights are around a round table because
they're all equal they all decided to go
off and look for the wrong table so they
all go look at the forest and each
Knight looks and sees where the forest
looks darkest to him and that's where he
stars it's like yes that's wisdom and I
learned that also from Carl Jung it
derived a dictum from alchemy instr : is
the inventory which means that which you
most need to find will be found where
you least want to look right but what's
so interesting and this I didn't expect
this is that
if you peer into the darkest dark you
find the brightest light and I never
expected that but that's what happened I
thought oh this is horrible horrible
even beyond what I could comprehend and
but but the light that can overcome that
that exists the light that can overcome
that exists it's actually real and I
think the instinct that we have that
manifests itself within us as meaning
which is what you feel for example when
you listen to music that you really love
you feel that sense of intrinsic meaning
that meaning is a guide to the light and
try to I don't mean I mean
metaphorically but I mean religiously
but I also mean biologically right in
reality that sense of meaning is the
guide to the light that overcomes the
darkness and the darkness is dark it's
really dark but that means the light is
that means the light has to be that much
brighter and it is I really believe that
I love that and you and just since
you've gone there it's like it's so real
man it's just seems so real when you say
it for some reason because you've done
the work you've seen you know you've
tried to start at that darkest spot and
then to still say that oh that's the
thing because and if and if that's not
the story though then there is no story
it's like that has to be the story that
we go that it ends in pathi that it ends
that it goes upward that otherwise
there's no there's nothing if that's not
the story yeah well that's a very good
way of looking at it that's I think that
so who would ever choose nothing it says
it's just such a pointless there's no
it's not just awful ease it's it's it's
Satan's it's Satan's dictum that things
are so terrible that it would be better
if there was nothing at all
yeah that's rude there's there's a whole
line of German literature
speculative literature that was that was
that was laid out by a man named Goethe
who wrote a play called Faust about a
man who owned a soul to the devil for
knowledge and mephistopheles features in
Faust he's the tempter he's he's Satan
himself and his credo is life is so
terrible it would be better if it was
replaced by nothing hmm turn apart it's
an apocalyptic desire not have that
there yeah we're all yeah well that's
the third times man I didn't know if I
would but you know if I think and even
the first thing because
like my little niece I saw her this
weekend you know and she would smile
yeah she was she had a cup full of
potato chips and she was just laying on
the dog's back that just met this dog
yeah I'm putting him in his mouth and
I'm like that exists better that that
exists there you go that's it that if a
million people had loss of whatever's
happened in the past yeah there's this
one moment right now that makes you know
and I don't even know if she knew you
know she's only 2 or something so we
don't even know each other really but
there's just one little moment that
maybe that's all works well so you know
in the last chapter my book it's called
pet account when you encounter one yes
and it's about it's about the
experiences I had my family had when my
daughter was unbelievably ill and
suffering like mad it's like well
because that's the real limit case is
this worthwhile it's like well what
about when a child is suffering an
innocent child is suffering terribly
it's like well how do you justify that
it part of that is well they're some of
the advice in that chapter is practical
but some of it is you notice those
things you notice those little
glimmerings of beauty and notice those
little glimmerings of of that sort of
transcendent reality and that's what
keeps you going and you saw that with
your you saw that with your niece and
you can see those things if you keep
your eyes open yep and you would better
cuz they keep you alive and what makes
me that what that what then I notice if
I'm able to do this then afterwards is
tell another person about it even if
it's like a man and it seems like it's
kind of like a weird thing to tell a
dude like it shows some vulnerability
for me yeah and also show some ability
to pay attention and see yeah whoo man
but it makes it it gives it even more
value for some reason like whatever I
can do if I can be vulnerable after it
somehow in some way well it's not just
that you're vulnerable it's that you
accept the vulnerability and you
transcend it at the same time which is
also what comedians do all the time
because a comedian always says ha ha ha
look at they're all we do or there's her
we stupid useless but but we can see
that we can rise above it yeah we are
that stupid and useless but we could
ride helmet and then the next joke comes
on and you know that's why that gesture
in the Kings Court was so valuable is he
who's the only person who can tell the
king the truth hmm right and the King
couldn't get mad because Oh cuz that was
his thing was beneath the gesture was
beneath contempt
you could let him do it say anything he
wants what's why two comedians are a
good bellwether in a free society if the
comedians don't get wherever a comedian
can't go that's a tyranny hmm where
can't they go University campuses right
you know City campuses right
the comedian say I won't go there it's
like oh why is that something cuz the
King is so T Roenick tyrannical he can't
he'll kill the jester it's like that's a
tyrant we have a question that pertains
right to that about the yeah that we
Nicki was talking about hey oh well the
show big fan of you big fan of professor
Peterson I've got a question for
Peterson
when does he think that all these
Marxist leaning professors really came
to prominence in academia because I
graduated from a philosophy program in
2011 and it just didn't seem that
radical or left-leaning to me the other
culture so the wondering if there's some
very recent change or professors that
have risen to prominence hike in the
last few years or if this has been its
sitting I just went to a more
level-headed place that's a good
question and I was listening to on Joe
Rogan talking about how you believe a
lot of this has started with college
campuses a lot of this you know you know
some of this wild thought and any way
you can answer this question but it well
the ideas have been lurking for a very
long time and they've manifested
themselves in various forms of Marxism
throughout the 20th century and of
course that has its historical
precursors I mean there was there was
quite an upswing of leftist thinking in
the 1960s and then that sort of faded
away to some degree through the 70s and
80s and then it popped back up in the
1990s there was quite a spike in
political correctness in in the early
1990s and then probably because the
American economy just started to boom
that sort of faded away and then in the
last five years it's just gone
completely well it's just we hit a
tipping point of some sort and why I
don't know and maybe in the philosophy
department you were somewhat but rest'
against that his philosophy is actually
one of the few disciplines on the
humanities end of the spectrum that
seems to have been relatively
uncorrupted I don't know I think we hit
a tipping
point of some sort and it might also be
that more and more administrators have
also become politically correct so it's
not just the faculty members it's also
the administrators and some of that's
under legislative pressure so it's not
only the fault of the universities I
don't know I think that you know
something can be the same for a long
time be slowly slowly changing so a
larger and larger minority of people are
a radicalized and and the people with
the contrary views are shut out and then
all of a sudden it's so many of them
that the whole thing just timpz and
something like that has happened and I
mean it's been quite well documented by
people like Jonathan height is that
there are no conservatives in the social
sciences so even the middle the Liberals
will like me that's basically my
position politically it's like I'm a
classical liberal it's like well you're
a right winger it's like only compared
to you Michael laughs it is that's how I
was I moved out here and I felt like
more liberal than the environment I was
from and then I get out here and you
can't even I mean men I was you couldn't
even talk during it I was afraid to talk
because of my accent yeah because of
having a southern accent any time during
the election like I believe in that like
and also from an industry that's
supposed to be so accepting it's like
Holly was like we're so accepting of
everyone but yet you know and I talked
about this and I was like you know black
actors and actresses where haven't we're
begging for Golden Globes two years ago
to be included you know or the Academy
Awards to be included you know saying
they weren't getting like and there's no
one this for the amount of people that
live in the area that I'm from there's
there's nobody there's two or three
people with southern accents even on
television you know or in like it's
right
I don't know it just I've just never
felt less welcome in a place in my life
that I fought so hard to get to and so
it's been I've had a you know a troubled
relationship with this industry
sometimes but thankfully to things like
podcasts and stuff like that it's
starting to book people are starting to
at least at least I can I can have some
sort of a voice because I can you know
create my own and my voice isn't even a
bad voice like I'm trying to come from a
great
place but it's just I don't know if this
never felt less welcome kind of mm-hmm
well you're creating your own audience
yeah so more power to you yeah you know
and you haven't been doing it for very
long so no yeah go a year-and-a-half
yeah I mean yeah and it's amazing how
the audience comes and then how they
lift you up and and that makes you feel
it makes you feel not embolden but makes
you feel like man I can trust my
instincts yeah little right right right
exactly were you always able to trust
your instincts in your life did you feel
like I was probably able to that didn't
mean I did yeah did you have trouble I
have a tribe yeah that's terrible
calibrating my incense man when I was
young when I was about 23 or 24 and I
first started to well started to do the
work that culminated in my first book
that took me about 15 years I had this
outline it in the preface of the book I
had this experience I was starting to
understand that that it was really not a
good idea to say things that weren't
true that you didn't believe to be true
and then sorry I started thinking that
through and I was also starting to
wrestle with this problem of malevolence
at the same time so those two things
kind of got tangled together and in some
way and I had this experience where I
kind of split in some sense and part of
me was the old part that was talking
like I was kind of a combat of talker
and I'm still you know I still talk a
lot it was always been part of my nature
and and I but part of me split off and
it was watching the part that was
talking it was going well you don't
believe that that's not really true
that's not really your idea it's like
you're just saying that to sound smart
you're just trying to win this argument
really critically I thought oh what the
hell's going on either this part that's
critical is correct and the other part
is not so good right the part that's
doing most of the talking is good and
what the hell's up with this critical
part I didn't know and I thought okay
but I did notice that there were some
things that critical part wouldn't
object to when I said wouldn't object
and I thought okay what if I tried to
not say anything that this critical part
objected to and so then I'd say
something and it would object and I
think you know I didn't get that right
and then I'd try to reformulate it and
continue to reformulate it and then
finally when I got to the point where I
stop saying most of those things and
this critical part stopped objecting and
then I noticed that all of the things
that I was saying that the critical part
was objecting to were actually things
that were making me weak Wow and they're
not full truth no they weren't they
weren't at all like I thought Oh 95
percent of what I said was some sort of
lie right whoa 95 percent man
that's a lot but that's another comedy
it's some of the comedy in the beginning
of comedy it's like I'm just telling
jokes to learn how to tell jokes a lot
of times I'm saying making up stuffing
and then now I've gotten more authentic
and that's when things have definitely
gotten brighter right whether it is
associated with that authenticity right
to find your authentic voice yeah right
which is the voice that you're that you
have a right to it's something like that
yeah you also have taken responsibility
for both oh that's interesting though a
voice that you have a right yeah well
because I have these ideas that I could
say but they weren't my ideas I didn't
have a right to them I haven't earned
them even though I could formulate the
idea as I've taken them from books say
ah so I could be a mouthpiece for the
ideas but I didn't have a right to them
they weren't mine I hadn't earned them
yeah and that's it that's crazy I feel
like there's a different type of person
in the world that has had to take
responsibility for themselves you know
and this had to earn their voice right
then they have a real voice they have a
real voice and they're not just saying
stuff they're not spraying like a donk
yes what happens in Pinocchio right yeah
he ends up transformed into a braying
jackass because he isn't saying the
truth yeah right your brain jackass it's
like well you have to earn it you have
to rescue your father from the abyss in
order to earn your voice yeah it's so
yeah that's exactly right down into the
depths and you have to earnest get in
there mm-hmm get in there
let's hear yeah this is good let's hear
this and this is more of a comment for
both you not a question thank you to
both you gentlemen because I'm in a
better place now in my life than I have
ever been you know and those are big
changes from the man that I was six
months ago you know and both of you were
there when the gears started turning and
you've been there throughout and I'm
making this call
now so I just want to say thanks man I
hope you guys continue to do what you do
you know to give people like me out here
strength and guidance you know people
like the man that I was six months ago
because I wasn't stagnant six months ago
you know I was getting worse you know
and I've done nothing but get better so
that that gap just continues to wideness
things go on and I don't know there's
just such a powerful thing it's just
such a powerful thing that you to do and
and I hope that you keep it up you know
I pray that you do and god bless both of
you thank you hey man this guy that's a
good video that's a good video man yeah
that's great
DS is great right right right you don't
stay stagnant you get worse I guess
swamp doesn't stop rotting right the rod
just gets deeper and deeper there's no
stagnant and and and staying the same
there's just stagnant and worse now that
was great that's what it's like being
doing this tour yeah and you know you
could tell that this while he looked
great was here look great yeah yeah and
then he was sincere right and so it's
moving it's at sincerity you talked
about yourselves moving eh yeah yeah
well sincerity is moving it moves you to
a better place that was great and that's
the sort of thing that people are
telling me when I'm out on this tour and
when they never get tired of that like
yes right on man right things are better
for you hooray and is there any way that
you that you notice you were able to
keep from that building up like that
that landing in an educational place for
you and that landing in an ego place for
you oh well it's just I'm just like well
I'm not attributing it to myself right
I'm attributing it to what you know to
the degree that I've been able to
facilitate that it's because I've been
I've had the privilege right of of
having the time to read all those these
great clinicians and to put that into
practice it's like the wisdom that's the
wisdom I did I'm not inventing the
wisdom that helps people redeem
themselves here's a Sherpa all right yes
that's exactly it to the degree that I
can be you know and so I'm not I'm not
taking credit for this I learned this
from Carl Jung too he wrote an essay
called the relation between the ego and
the unconscious which is exact
about this it's a hard se to know what
it's about unless you know what it's
about and this is what it's about he
said don't mistake yourself for the
wisdom don't do that it's like because
the wisdom is eternal right there is no
be here before you and that will be here
after you're gone and maybe if you're
fortunate you can you can you can you
can bridge the gap you can you can tap
into it you can you can dip your you can
dip your cup into it maybe you can do
that but you're you're it's like you
know you're the surfer and you're not
the wave it's like you're you might be
the cup but you're not the well and so
you need to know that and so when I hear
this I think well yeah right what I hear
is yeah this information had the same
effect on me
so yes hooray but I don't think like
then I've done that it's like no I'm
pleased to be a part of it is what I
think I'm pleased to be a part of it and
that's definitely the case yeah what I
hear is that you're grateful to be the
cup you remind yourself that well and
I'm so happy I think when I hear someone
when I hear someone say that I think
okay a you're not descending towards
hell and that's great because if you go
to hell deep enough you can take a lot
of people with you yes alright at
minimum you're this this gentleman is
much less likely to do reprehensible and
terrible things that that's a big plus
but it also looks like he's one of the
good stuff yeah it's all he's on the
path he's doing more for himself and
maybe he's gonna be good for other
people too it's like god only knows how
that might manifest itself because
people are quite remarkable and if they
stop getting in their own way it's like
the sky is the limit
right and really it really is sky really
is the literally is increas man god only
knows what we could come up with I mean
look what we've come up with in the last
20 years yeah so and who knows where we
could go especially if all of us were
pulling together man
who knows where we could end up I love
it make you wanna play another one
you know dr. Pearson I'm a big admirer
of yours and I really enjoyed your event
at the Beacon Theatre in New York City
back in March but my question to you is
how do you manage to keep your colon and
computations and and highly stressful
situations you know you're kind of like
Canadian psychology version of the fine
my opinion and one situation I'd like to
refer to is during the month debate
where Michael Tyson I think his
neighbor's he made that comment
referring to you as a mean mad white man
and you know you managed to stay on
topic not let it you know make you angry
or anything and I'm serious things you
wanted to say to him
you kamancheh stay on topic and keep
your cool so you know any advice don't
have it on how to do that would be great
today that's a great question it's a
great when we get rattled how do we stay
cool so we can stay on message and stay
on indirection
well you have to kind of decide what
you're aiming out you know and I mean in
a fundamental sense because that helps
you stay oriented you know I'm not
trying to bring excess damage into the
world and so partly what you do is when
you're attacked as you you can defend
yourself with minimal necessary force
and I really mean it's a real art to use
minimum force and it works way better
it's a way more effective form of
defense and so like I didn't let what he
said go unopposed I said that there to
him that there was no excuse to bring
like he can call me a mean mad man
that's fine because maybe it's true and
he's certainly entitled to that opinion
but to add white to that just seemed to
bring an arbitrary element of racism in
and so that's what I said and that was a
good enough defense but also in those
public fora it doesn't hurt at all to
let people expose their agenda and so if
your attack do you think was this a good
thing or a bad thing it's like well it's
it's an awkward thing and it can be an
aggravating thing but it isn't
necessarily a bad thing to let people
who are attacking you for unwarranted
reasons reveal their full agenda do you
see their weapons then well yeah I knew
that one you can see you can see them
right it's like okay well what are you
up to attacking me well it's cuz you're
bad it's like maybe go on with your
attack right now I'm gonna do with me
right now so learning a lot about me yes
if that's the question is who is this
taco who is this attack about well maybe
it's about me maybe it's about you yeah
and so if that's public it's like I'm
willing to the degree that I can manage
this
I'm willing to to allow the attacks to
progress because I think I'm hoping that
they might be about the attacker and not
about me you know an ounce it's a hairy
game in some sense a high-stress game
because there are things about me you
know because no one's perfect yeah sure
and so some of the punches land but but
most of the time and this has happened
over and over again it's like no they
attacks reveal more about the attacker
than me yeah and so that's been good and
so then that's a strange thing it's like
well what why should I be thinking that
this attack is bad it's uncomfortable
it's stressful and all of that but some
of the best things that have happened to
me let's say over the medium to long run
in the last two years have emerged
directly from the most vicious and
unwarranted attacks it's like well no
they didn't use knives so that's good
right recover from that you know so I
know there's a limit to this sort of
argumentation when you are liking that
similarly in comedy sometimes I used to
think it's always me saying stuff that
is the funniest art can build up the
most credibility with the audience but
now I'm realizing it's almost times when
I'm silent that reveals more about the
story sometimes it's a little bit of an
inverse of what you're saying dishes use
of silence is quite helpful you know one
right but I never thought of that as
like being something that would reveal
anything right whereas you would never
think if somebody attacks you sitting in
silence or you know minimal response
using the most effective response right
because retaliation that's not even
that's retaliation they're not even uh
it's well unorganized well the thing is
you do have the you do have the right
and maybe even the responsibility to
defend yourself but the question is
what's the most effective defense and
it's sort of like when you're
disciplining children it's like well how
much force do you use the minimum
necessary the absolute minimum necessary
now that takes a lot of judicious
interaction it takes a lot of judgment
to get that absolutely right but it's
the same in a public forum it's like
well how hard should I defend myself
well
turns out my experience has taught me
over and over minimum necessary force
and so it's probably even better well
it's not better to err on the side of
less force you don't want to err at all
but little detachment little patience a
little faith in the judgment of the
audience that's the other thing it's
like that's because that's the other
thing I think is like if this if this
everything plays out then people will
make the right judgment not everyone of
course not everyone but wisdom will
prevail right that's what I think
willing to I'm willing to see if that's
the case willing to assume that that
will be the case do you how do you prep
for debate is it like you have a
Gatorade or some before can you do
bubbly water well the only thing I eat
is like sparkling water and mate so
that's I have some sparkly it's like
it's so funny these tours a and and if
you're a tour if you're renting theaters
they ask you well what do you want
before the tour right so you you can you
can pretty much specify whatever like
warier and prosciutto well that's like
I'll have six six bubbly waters like
that's all you want it's like yeah I
know it's really sad I could have 20
dancing girls and hold my fan stone you
got some water put some bubbles in it
man because we'll have a real party then
we what is like a um and I know you have
a you know your special diet but it's
like uh what's a guilty pleasure kind of
tell me you have a Ricci Cup at peanut
butter cup now yeah well I'd I'm not I'm
not I'm really that's all I'm eating and
I never cheat like that's it period
that's what I eat now I'm hoping to
expand that outward again as I
experiment with what I can tolerate but
right now it's like it's religious
I never cheat I eat beef and salt and
water and that's it I know it's crazy
man why you're like a ninja I told it
sounds like something it's not like a
rare Japanese ridiculous huh but it
works yeah that's the thing it's helped
me a lot and it's cured my daughter and
it works for you and it works your blood
ties before say their daughter and for
anyone else but it does work for her and
it has worked for my wife as well so
well what is something special that uh
music is a pleasure I mean I have a car
I rented the car rented a Mustang GT
which I really like
vertical and it's got a nice loud stereo
and so I love loud music I love zooming
around in sports car listening to loud
music I really like that I could do that
I did that all the time when I was a kid
it isn't a sports car but what kind of
music you listening to I don't see some
James Blake maybe or some Chopin oh you
know if I said it really listen to
classical music in a convertible because
the dynamic range is so how you miss
most and you're creeping people out well
there's that too it's like what the hell
is I know I like I mean I listen to all
sorts of dinosaur rock but I have a big
collection of music that goes right from
the 1930s til til now you know and my
son and my daughter both feed me new new
relatively new nice like for me if it's
five years old it's still new you know I
really like Arcade Fire Canadian band oh
yeah bloody great I like beach house I
like him band name I can't remember the
name of it's like the vodka - vodka -
vodka from Seattle oh wow they play our
kind of a Russian oriented folk rock
which I really heavy rock I really like
that I really think they're great and
like Gogol Bordello they say oh man
they're wild they have a song called
start wearing purple you should watch it
there the guy that lead singers at just
a wild man he has an accent that you
cannot believe exists it sounds like a
parody of an Eastern European accent
sounds like he's putting it over at or
something yeah like that exactly yeah
he's like Borat if that's right if Borat
what had a rock band this would be at
Gogol Bordello
I love them well if they love Tom Waits
I'll check him out yeah and I love the
UM weights man I think he's absolutely
great he's one of those guys that's just
tough as a bloody boot I love to watch
him with who's the talk show host had
always made fun of everybody just
retired Dave Letterman Letterman yeah
cuz Letterman was pretty hard like ah
hey I like Letterman too but he was
pretty much no celebrity intimidated him
right Tom Waits man intimidated America
Beckham was really fun cuz they're like
Letterman's like a little kid around Tom
Waits while Tom Waits is so tough and
cool and such a bloody genius that and
every time he puts out an album I think
oh Jesus Tom you just went off the deep
end this time it's too damn much I can't
listen to this it's too harsh and I
listen to it like five times and I think
God he hit it out of the park yeah
and also what about like Leonard Cohen
did you listen to him oh yeah definitely
I loved Leonard Cohen yeah yeah it was
really sad when he died I saw a concert
of Leonard Cohen about five years ago
and he was like 82 and it was like a
religious experience Wow everybody gave
him a standing ovation when he showed up
was that the Sony Center so the
acoustics were great and he just bloody
nailed it he got better and better as he
got older
like Johnny cows gained cash got yeah
it's got better to his last few albums
man he was in a transcendent space man
that song yeah he was in he was in the
zone he was the only old guy so and
that's for sure
do you feel like it things changing as
you get a little bit older because I
mean you seem very young and you look
extremely healthy do you all beef diet
it is ya know you definitely seem like
I'm surprised I didn't catch you eating
grass out front you know but do you
start to feel anything for herbivores
these it's hard to feel anything no
because you turned into a cow
yeah yeah oh but do you start to feel
anything being different as you get
older like are you noticing anything or
well my family means more and more to me
wow I would say that's that's that's
become I mean they've always meant a lot
right but but you notice that that even
deep is definitely why you want to have
kids man is because you're gonna get old
it's not the only reason to have kids
and there's lots of reason to have kids
but the older you get the more important
your family is you know and so because I
don't know why it is exactly it's why
don't why exactly buddy it may be
because he gets smarter you get wiser
it's like yeah you guys are really
important to me it's really important
that we do this right so and maybe you
want something in the world to know that
you loved it yeah yeah well there's that
I mean that's right that's that's that
that's the focus right yep that's where
it is and that turns out that's really
important so yeah so and I'll have a new
grandchild and that's really cool oh but
she must she's she's how old is she now
she must be about nine months so haven't
seen her for a month that's fun because
they start really moving around even
around now man that's such a blessing we
have one more question and then we'll um
and we'll wrap it up I guess relating to
children
here's one about Santa Claus okay I love
Santa
so he'll they love the park
his messages for Jordan Peterson I don't
know how you think about addressing
Santa Claus with children and when and
what what age is a good time to make
sure that he's not the live kick no you
don't want to move you that's good to
know yeah but you don't want him to be
the laughs yeah it's best in Canada you
guys are closer to Santa to deal with
this move yeah yeah exactly it's more
real man oh yeah it's a good question I
would say like if you're doing
everything you can to reward your kid
for being awake and alert and and
figuring things out you probably don't
have to worry about it because if he's
sharp and with it he won't be the first
or the last he won't and if he is the
first he won't tell the other kids and
spoil it either if he's if he's together
so I would say don't worry about it too
much it's a good game to play with kids
Santa Claus you know and it it is kind
of based on the idea that if you're good
there'll be there'll be something in it
for the future and so you know you might
think well it's a lie to tell your kids
that Santa Claus exists but it's it's
not a lie it's a game it's like a drama
or a play it's a lot I mean like a movie
isn't a lie right it's fictional but
it's not a lie story it's a story and
Santa Claus is a fiction it's a little
theater that you have with your family
and your kid will clue in and start
asking and I'd say when they ask you can
say look it's a game that we played and
it's a fun game and it's for kids and
now you're older and good for you you're
growing up and you figured it out and
you give them a pat for being so smart
you say well when you're older you can
play Santa Claus with your kids and then
you'll have fun too so you get it
because it's a bit of a loss when a kid
figures out that Santa Claus doesn't
exist and maybe they feel like a bit of
a fool and they can't trust their
parents right they don't usually but if
you tell them look it's a game it's a
theatrical game and you play it for kids
now you've now you clued in and so it
means you're getting older and more
mature and you give them a path you say
good for you and like wasn't that fun
and and then that's the end of that and
and and then you can do it again when
you have grandkids if you're lucky yeah
but if your kid if you're if you reward
your kid for being sharp they'll figure
it out you don't have to worry about
that too much is there um is it tough
having you as a parent you think for
your kids you mean now yeah I think it's
probably always been tough in some ways
because I'm kind of a strange person
right but I think it's well you're
definitely a unique person okay so yeah
I guess that's what I mean like I guess
what has it been like you feel like for
your kids having Jordan Peterson as a
parent well I think it's been good I
have a really good relationship other
both of them you know and I have I've
had a good relationship with my kids
ever since they were little I really
liked being with them and we've made I
like them when they were little kids I
like them when they were toddlers I like
them when they were teenagers we've had
a fine relationship all the way through
and we still have a really good
relationship so I think it's been really
good you know I've always assumed that
they'd given the opportunity they would
be sufficiently sensible and I called on
them a lot you know to be sensible um my
both my daughter and my son it was
complicated with my daughter because she
was so sick but my son he's been a damn
trooper and like I expected right from
the time he was little it's like you you
you you're you're you I expected him to
abide by the truth and to be a
responsible person right from the time
he was little and he always was and like
he was in on the decisions and he was
great he his sister relied on him when
she was sick and he was around and he
didn't cause any excess trouble he was
no you know my son Julian he's perfectly
capable of getting into the appropriate
amount of trouble and not probably to do
it yeah but he kept it to himself and he
didn't bring any of his troubles home
except when it was absolutely necessary
and he didn't add any additional burden
to us well we were completely swamped
with my daughter's illness and so I was
incredibly impressed with that that was
between when he was 13 and 16 or so yeah
and he you think a kid would then
because you know there if anything it
also might have some unknown jealousy
that they're feeling because as a child
getting more attention of course well my
daughter even got jealous of herself
because she well she was jealous because
her illness got all the attention
hmm right and so it was worse in some
sense for my son how did that test your
sorry going on oh how did it test your
faith when your daughter got ill did you
have any did you have a lot of fear
there well it just made not being
inhaled more important right right
because there was no time for that yeah
there was barely enough time to keep
things
happening any additional trouble mm-hmm
we would have been done yeah so luckily
we had got the trouble to a minimum by
that point my wife and I we we our
relationship was good my relationship
was solid with my son it was solid with
my parents was solid with my in-laws
like everything was put in place and of
course that was most important with the
immediate family and and that was thank
God you know the arc was cocked that
there were no there were no chinks
between the Timbers when the flood came
we didn't found her in sync thirteen
yeah yeah we were a team and really and
thank God because there's no way we
would have made it otherwise mm-hmm my
daughter wouldn't have made it and god
only knows what that would have done to
the rest of us so and we did make it and
she's healthy now and so thank God for
that
it's a miracle when you're out of town
Mikey you're on tour right now how does
your wife deal with that Jeremy comes
with me oh she does yes she travels I
saw a cute we had a caller that called
and said they didn't see laughs very
much in like you know obviously your
basic for two years well but then I saw
a video of you talking about your wife
and you guys were kids and you were
laughing all the way through it and I
thought it was just pretty true yeah
well you laughed plenty today yeah yeah
well today with you oh that's true wait
man yeah we had a nice time Jordan thank
you so much like we just you know we
really appreciate you being here hey
it was a pleasure talking with you and
with your audience yeah and the
opportunity yeah and we'll be following
in and supporting and learning and
questioning as you move forward and yeah
we're just I guess all of us feel like
we're on like this journey together and
we're glad that you know we're not alone
out there absolutely man that's great
it's great to have an opportunity to
talk to your audience and I wish them
well
yep I know you do thank you so much
[Music]
I'm full and like these leaves I must be
oh but when I reach that I'll share this
piece of thought it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]